Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio zweihundertsechsundsiebzig, wo wir uns jetzt mit einem Thema beschäftigen wollen, das schon
nicht mehr aktuell ist, weil es den aktuellen Nachrichtenzyklus so ein bisschen verlassen hat und es gibt andere wichtige Dinge, aber was andererseits brandaktuell ist, weil es noch lange nicht vorbei ist, wovon ich rede, ist die sogenannte Chatkontrolle.
Selbst wenn ihr davon noch nichts gehört habt, habt ihr wahrscheinlich das Wort schon mal gehört, weil es tatsächlich für ein paar hm Tage, Wochen
sehr gut durch die Medien flog und jetzt immer noch so ein bisschen immanent da ist, aber schon ein bisschen weniger. Und wir wollen das heute, wie es Chaosradioart ist, eben einmal auseinandernehmen, aufrollen, wieder zumachen und dann gucken, was wir dagegen unternehmen können, weil ja, es ist eines dieser Themen
wo Dinge anstehen. Und dazu begrüße ich recht herzlich Kalisi und Viktor. Zwei Menschen, die sich mit diesem Thema beschäftigt haben, vor allen Dingen mit dem Auseinandernehmen.
Und ähm die heute hier zu Gast sind. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Hallo. Hi.
Ähm der Reihe nach, wer seid ihr? Was macht ihr und was befähigt euch über das Thema Chatkontrolle zu sprechen? Kalisi?
Hallo, ich bin Kalisi, ich bin Mitglied im Chaos Computer Club und in der AG Kritis und bei den Hexen. Die Hexen, wer es nicht kennt, sind die Frauen im Chaos-Computerclub aktiv
und beschäftige mich schon, ich würde sagen beruflich jedenfalls locker vier Jahre mit Themen von Informationssicherheit und Datenschutz
und habe dann auf Twitter rumgepöbelt, warum denn niemand was in der Zivilgesellschaft für Personen außerhalb der Chaos Bubble, gegen die Chat-Kontrolle organisiert
und dann tat sich diese Kampagne auf und genau, jetzt bin ich sehr tief in dem Chat-Kontrollenthema drin.
Und rede auch sehr viel dadrüber. Jetzt wer aber wer Hexen erklärt, muss auch Agigrites erklären
Okay, die ist die Arbeitsgruppe für kritische Infrastrukturen. Der ein oder andere, der Honkhase auf Twitter folgt, äh weiß, dass das ein massives Problem ist und wir setzen uns für.
Bessere Sicherheit von kritischen Infrastrukturen und bessere Gesetzgebung ein. Ja, genau.
Ein total gut vorbereiteter Chaosradiomoderator wäre, dann müsste ich nicht jetzt in diesem Moment googeln, welche Chaosradiofolge die Chaosradiofolge zur kritischen Infrastruktur ist, aber weil ich das sehr schnell kann, kann ich sagen, es ist Chaosradio 2hundertdreiundsechzig, wollte sich das genauer interessiert, könnt ihr genau da mal reinhören.
Viktor. Hi, wer bist du? Was machst du hier? Äh was mache ich hier?
Ich ähm habe früher einmal äh im Jahr 2017 einen Datenschutzverein namens digitale Freiheit mitgegründet und dafür damit haben wir sehr lange sehr viele schöne Dinge getan.
Da äh bin ich mittlerweile ähm etwas mehr raus und bin mittlerweile beim Chaos Computerclub aktiv und engagiere mich da.
Und im Rahmen meines Engagements da äh beschäftige ich mich sehr viel mit der Chat-Kontrolle und das auch schon seit sehr vielen äh Wochen bis Monaten.
Und ähm ja in diesem Rahmen glaube ich habe ich dazu einiges gelesen und einiges darüber nachgedacht und ich hoffe, das qualifiziert mich hier zu stehen.
Ah ja, letzte Sache noch das muss doch noch sagen, ich spiele in einer Datenschutzband.
Zufälligerweise in der Datenschutzband, die das aktuelle Chaosradio Auto stellt,
und deshalb ist das natürlich sehr große Ehre für mich erst irgendwie kann ich vielleicht kurz sagen, wir haben damals, als wir angefangen haben, Musik zu machen, war unser immer unser Ziel einmal im Chaosradio zu laufen.
Und äh das ist jetzt natürlich ähm sehr schön auch mal im Chaosradio zu stehen, in einer Folge, in der das wohl auch der Autosong werden wird
Dürfen wir uns noch einen aussuchen? Könnte man dann könnte man sagen, hat geklappt. Ähm ich frage mich jetzt schon sagen, wie die Verschwörungserzählung jetzt losgehen. Was? Die Leute, die Band jetzt darf auch noch was sagen zum Thema. Ist denn das irgendwie
doch alles ein riesiges Netzwerk, wie hängt das zusammen inhaltliche Neutralität. Politisch sein. Also das geht doch überhaupt gar nicht. So, jetzt habt ihr aber ganz oft das Wort Chatkontrolle gesagt. Mhm. Ja. Ähm
Wahrscheinlich sozusagen zwei von Menschen. Die einen, die sozusagen das Thema verfolgt haben und jetzt gleich gespannt sein werden, okay, was kann man da noch zu sagen? Und die anderen, die so OK-Chat-Kontrolle
habe ich so oft gehört, jetzt will ich wissen, was das ist, ich schalte etwas Chaosradio ein, die Sendung für den angewandten Wissentransfer und.
Um mal diese Frage zu stellen, was ist das eigentlich, aber mitten im Setting?
Also, ich war die das letzte halbe Jahr auf einer Insel, habe nicht so richtig Ahnung von Technik, komme aber jetzt zurück und habe gesehen,
Menschen regen sich über Chatkontrolle auf. Riesiges Thema, also nicht so nicht so ganz weit oben, aber ist doch irgendwie immer wieder und so. Und was ist denn das? Was ist denn eine Chatkontrolle? Was was wollen die was passiert denn da? Wer will denn da was?
Ted-Kontrolle. Entschuldigung.
Guten Tag, dass du von der Insel wiedergekommen bist. Schön, dass du nicht verhungert bist. Ähm die Chat-Kontrolle ist der politisch gefärbte Begriff für die aktuelle,
Initiative der EU-Kommission. Sie nennen das selber zum Schutz von Kindern in der praktischen, technischen Realität würde das bedeuten, dass äh hochwahrscheinlich.
Ähm Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Messenger.
Gescannt werden würden jede Nachricht und jeder Text und das wäre ein Problem weil wir dann nicht mehr wirklich vertrauen könnten dass die sehr vertrauensvollen Nachrichten, die wir da schicken,
nur da landen, wo sie ankommen, wo sie landen, sondern vielleicht auch bei der Polizei ganz schlecht. Halt! Okay, okay, okay, also ich.
Wenn ich mich aufmerksamen Ort zuhöre, ja? Mhm. Hast du zum Beispiel gerade gesagt, würde das in der technischen Realität bedeuten, dass mhm.
Das heißt also schon, es hat niemand vorgeschlagen, lass uns mal Chats überwachen. Genau, also vielleicht machen wir nochmal einen Schritt zurück und gehen zu dem Wort zurück, nämlich Chat und Kontrolle.
Wie kommt man nämlich dazu? Also vielleicht kommen wir noch so. Wer eigentlich?
Wer wer diese Überwachung durchführt? Ja, wer will Chatkontrolle? Also die.
EU-Kommission wird Chat-Kontrolle. Allen voran ähm der EU-Kommissar die EU-Kommissarin Elva Johansen und in freundlicher Kooperation.
Mit Ursula von der Leyen, die kennen wir ja schon von früher. Zensola hat man sie früher auch geheißen, auch dazu gibt's eine Chaos-Radiofolge.
Genau und die EU-Kommission will Kinder online besser schützen. Das ist so ein bisschen die das Narrativ zu dieser ganzen Verordnung.
Mhm. Und was da passieren soll, ist konkret, jede ähm Kommunikation zwischen Menschen online.
Zu kontrollieren, deswegen Chatkontrolle und zwar zu kontrollieren dadrauf, ob Kindesmissbrauchs-Darstellung ausgetauscht werden.
Kurzergänzung oder ob Anmachversuche von,
älteren Menschen an jüngere Kinder passieren. Das heißt, es geht sowohl um die Bilder, als auch um die Texte. Was die Dinge sind, die man typischerweise in einem Chat, also einem Messenger, austauscht.
Darum geht's hier. Also Moment, aber in dem Vorschlag der EU-Kommission, da steht erstmal nur drin, wir wollen Kommunikation daraufhin oder.
Die Frage ist, wie tief möchtest du jetzt in den Gesetzesentwurf einsteigen?
Gar nicht so tief. Nur nur sozusagen nur sozusagen wissen wollt oder andersrum. Also ich kenne das Internet ja so
Ja, das Internet hat sozusagen zwei Funktionen. Das eine ist so eine quasi öffentliche, also ich
poste irgendwas. Das hat dann vielleicht auch irgendwie soziale Funktionen mit Liken und Teilen und Kommentieren und so, aber es ist im Prinzip öffentlich und es gibt irgendwie das ganze Webseiten und Krimskrams und Pipapo und dann gibt es ähm so interpersonelle Kommunikation im Weizen Sinne, also,
Ich spreche oder Videochat oder was mit irgendjemand anders oder auch mit mehreren Leuten, aber es ist bei bei einem analogen Bild zu bleiben ein geschlossener Raum. Dieser Vorschlag jetzt.
Bezieht er sich auf diese, ich nenne sie jetzt mal interpersonelle Kommunikation, egal auf welchem Kanal oder auf das ganze Internet. Es geht.
Erst mal um alles, worüber wir hier aber reden, ist vor allem die interpersonelle Kommunikation, weil das die größte Gefahr ist, die hier betroffen
sein könnte. Also nochmal kurz zur Einordnung. Es ist ein sehr komplexer Gesetzesentwurf, der dadurch komplex wird, weil er erstens überhaupt nicht eingeschränkt wird. Da steht dieser Gesetzesentwurf gilt für,
App Stores und alles Mögliche und äh eben auch ähm alles, wo Menschen kommunizieren mhm. Und das zweite Spannende ist, dieser Gesetzentwurf sieht,
ist erstmal sehr schwammig, sondern schreibt Ziele vor und er sagt, schreibt im Prinzip was? Das äh relativ radikale Zielvorfahren, es soll einfach nicht mehr passieren.
Dass Leute äh Kindesmissbrauchsabbildung sich untereinander verschicken, was hier ein total super Ziel ist. Also niemand würde dem widersprechen. Ähm es schreibt aber überhaupt keine technischen Umsetzungen vor und.
Dadurch aber in der ähm radikalen Zielerreichung passieren, die die ist gar nicht anders möglich.
Als auf den Geräten über die verschlüsselt kommuniziert wird, Inhalte zu scannen, ob da vielleicht nicht doch etwa.
Kindesmissbrauchsabbildung oder entsprechende Texte verschickt wurden. Weil, wenn das sonst verschlüsselt wäre, kann man da ja nicht mehr ran. Ne, das ist ja beendet zu Ende-Verschlüsselung. Es ist nur auf den Geräten.
Sichtbar die Kommunikation,
Mhm. Und das ist das Problem. Darum geht's hier. Also äh kann man sich jetzt so so vorstellen, also wenn wenn Menschen im Internet miteinander kommunizieren, dann redet Person A mit
Person B. Ich glaube Alice und Bob heißen in diesen Beispielen immer. Ähm und der Kommunikationskanal ist verschlüsselt, was das heißt, klären wir sozusagen heute noch mal ein bisschen genauer. Also denn der ist verschlüsselt und.
Das Gesetz geht quasi davon aus, wenn's da erstmal drin ist, dann kommt man auch nicht mehr ran. Und deswegen sollen Dinge überprüft werden, bevor es verschlüsselt wird oder ist das auch schon wieder Interpretation und steht eigentlich gar nicht in dem Gesetz drin?
Genau das ist wieder Interpretation dieses Gesetz ist Technologie unabhängig das ist so ein,
alter Trick von EU-Gesetzgebung. Das heißt, alles kann, nichts muss.
Aber wenn man tiefer in das Gesetz einsteigt, was wir wahrscheinlich gleich noch machen werden, kommt man zu dem Ergebnis, dass genau das implizit gefordert ist.
Also das Gesetz sagt.
Es soll verhindert werden, dass Abbildungen von Kindesmissbrauch oder Anbahnung von Missbrauchshandlungen.
Punkt. Mehr oder weniger. Ja. So
Und dass dass diese diese Strategie kennen wir schon von den Upload-Filtern da waren mich ebenfalls nicht von Upload-Filtern die Rede. Es haben aber alle gesagt ja witzig wenn ihr ähm sagt dass die Plattform dafür haften dann wird es keine andere Möglichkeit geben als das. Also ich.
Ich vermute sozusagen, wenn dein Song am Ende des oder euer Song am Ende des Chaos Radios läuft, weißt du auch die Chaos-Radio-Regel, ne. Wer Upload-Filter sagt, muss auch.
Kurz erklären, was er gut findet. Oh Gott, okay. Ähm ähm Upload-Filter ist eine ein ein weitere ähm netzpolitische Schlacht.
Im Jahre 2019 größtenteils passiert ist und da ging es um eine Urheberrechtsreform auf EU-Ebene.
Und da haben vor allem unter ähm der Wortführerschaft von vielen Verlags und Medienhäusern wurde gefordert, dass ähm.
Auch platt. Ich glaube, dass Plattformen dafür haftbar sind, wenn irgendwo überall rechts geschütztes Material.
Hochgeladen ist, auch wenn es in kleinen Teilen, auch wenn es in kleinen Snaps passiert
und die technische Community hat dann gesagt, effektiv würde das bedeuten, dass sämtliches Material, was hochgeladen wird
durch sogenannte Uploadfilter durchgehen, die dann sagen, ja, darfst du hochladen oder nein, darfst du nicht hochladen. Und die Aufregung war dann, weil Leute Angst hatten, dass ähm dann man
sich nicht wehren kann, wenn der Algorithmus sagt, nö
Dein Snippet will ich nicht oder dass man sich nicht wehren kann, wenn bei dem Video, was man hochladen möchte, zufällig irgendwo im Hintergrund, im Radio, irgendein Song läuft, der urberrechtlich geschützt ist und dass das zu drakonisch wird
und äh da gab es äh riesige Debattenproteste-Petitionen.
Und sehe dazu. Und sicherlich eine Chaos-Radiofolge dazu. Guckt in die Shownotes. Ich habe die Nummer jetzt sozusagen nicht parallel rausgeholt. Ähm.
Genau, der wichtige Punkt, ne und das das ist die erste Gemeinsamkeit ist ja genau das. In dem Vorschlag.
Was gefordert und es wird so getan, als wäre das sozusagen, ne? Also und dann könnt ihr euch bitte eurer Technologie aus äh ausdenken dazu und das ist eben, das kann man bei den Upload-Filtern schon sehen. Es ist eben nicht möglich, sondern.
Wenn wenn sich das Leute angucken, die von der Materie Ahnung haben, das was ja selten genug der Fall ist bei EU-Gesetzesvorschläge hat man euch den Eindruck, dann ist eben das die einzige mögliche Konsequenz. Um jetzt die Analogie nochmal zu ziehen ähm bei den Upload-Filtern war's ja so, das sollten.
Die Plattform machen. Ne, das war die Idee.
Die Plattformen sollen sollen irgendwie dafür sorgen und dann war die Technologie die technologische Konsequenz wäre die Plattform würden zum Beispiel in ihren Apps eben sozusagen so eine.
Voll automatisierte Entscheidung treffen. An wen ist denn das jetzt bei dem bei dem Vorschlag jetzt gedacht? Also wer soll denn da die Plattform verantwortlich? Ich würde das einmal ganz kurz erläutern, damit das ein bisschen besser verständlich ist, denn.
Auch schon gesagt hast, ist sehr schwammig, es ist aber auch sehr wasserdicht dieses Gesetz. Das heißt, was die Plattformen tun müssen, ist ein sogenanntes Risk Assessment zu machen. Das heißt, zu evaluieren
wie hoch das Risiko sein könnte, dass.
Kinderpornograf äh Kinder Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellung über ihre Plattform verbreitet werden könnten. Und anhand von dieser Evaluation müssen sie Medikation ergreifen, das heißt.
Dinge, die das verhindern würden.
Und es gibt in jedem EU-Land dann Behörden, die grundsätzlich darüber entscheiden, ob diese Maßnahmen, die die Plattform ergriffen hat,
angemessen sind. Die können aber auch noch schärfen am Anordnen und die Plattform werden grundsätzlich haftbar dafür gemacht.
Das ist der entscheidende Punkt, weil sobald man sagt, dass es original auch bei den Upload-Filtern wurde gesagt, die Plattformen sind haftbar für Fehler.
Und deshalb halten wir und alle Menschen, die sich damit ein bisschen beschäftigt haben, ist für extrem wahrscheinlich, dass es tatsächlich überall kommen wird, weil,
du dafür haftbar bist, dann wirst du aus einem betriebswirtschaftlichen Risiko wirst du mehr oder weniger dazu gezwungen, im Zweifelsfall die ein bisschen zu krasse
Verhinderungsmaßnahme zu treffen, weil du's dir nicht leisten kannst zu sagen, ah ja, okay, dann passiert das mal, irgendwie. Keine Ahnung, tausend Mal pro Jahr. Ist zwar kein signifikanter Teil, trägt auch nicht signifikant zu dem eigentlichen Problem bei, aber es wird einzelne Fälle geben.
Und dadurch.
Halten wir es eben für extrem wahrscheinlich bis hin zu sicher, dass das sich auch auf Messenger ausweiten wird. Das Interessante ist halt, dass es nicht nur so ist, dass die.
Anbieterinnen.
Zu sehr überzogenen Maßnahmen greifen können, die Behörden können das auch anordnen, wenn sie im Rahmen dieses Griss Assessment sehen
dass die Anbieterin nicht genug dafür getan haben, das zu verhindern. Das heißt, sie können das erkennen, das berichten, das Löschen und das Blocken von solchen Inhalten.
Per Anordnung juristisch gültig machen und könnten so auch Anbieterinnen dazu zwingen zu scannen zum Beispiel.
Mhm. Jetzt äh jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich die Stelle, wo man das Ding so ein bisschen auseinandernehmen muss ähm und das eine ist.
Man die äh die Diskussion uns klar trennen muss eben, dass es hier um interpersonelle Kommunikation geht, ne. Es ist ja die Plattform, die sozialen Netzwerke
Um das andere, um das Gegenteil zu beschreiben, die sagen ja immer so, ja gut, was hier gepostet wird, das hat mit uns jetzt aber nichts wirklich zu tun und das ist natürlich bisschen schwierig, wenn wir irgendwie von einem Facebook oder einem Twitter reden, wo einfach politische Kommunikation und Beeinflussung passiert.
Aber wenn wir über Interpersonelle Kommunikation
oder Telekommunikation, wie es in Deutschland heißt, reden, dann ist das halt ein anderer Schuh. Die soll tatsächlich Plattform agnostisch ist, glaube ich, das Wort sein, also im Sinne von da ist der Anbieter dafür zuständig, die Infrastruktur hochzustellen, der hat aber mit den Inhalten tatsächlich nichts zu tun.
Die Schnittstelle, wo man ganz gut sehen kann, wo die wo der Grad liegt, ist Telegram.
Ne, da wird tatsächlich gestritten, Telegram, wenn man da irgendwie miteinander redet, dann ist das eigentlich Telekommunikation, aber wenn ein veganer Koch irgendwie 30.000 Followern hat und da denkt, dann ist das vielleicht doch schon irgendwie was anderes.
Ist das vielleicht ein Telemedienanbieter? So und das ist halt eben das Besondere bei der Chatkontrolle, ne? Wir reden hier darüber, dass auf einmal.
Es so sein soll, dass also die Anbieter eines Dienstes dafür zuständig sind.
Doch irgendwie, ne, also wenn ich euch richtig verstanden habe, dass diese dieser Vorschlag ist erstmal total technisch neutral. Also irgendwie müssen der Anbieter halt sicherstellen, dass wir da nichts machen, was dagegen verstößt.
Ich möchte an der äh Stelle schon mal eine kleine Seitenkurve nehmen und zwar die Anbieter. Wenn man jetzt ein Telegram hat.
Oder einen Gmail oder einen Signal, dann ist der Anbieter relativ klar zu benennen
Aber jetzt gibt's ja auch diese ganzen verrückten Computerleute, die irgendwie dezentrale Dienste machen und so. Hat man sich gibt's da schon Gedanken drüber, wer Anbieter ist? Ist jeder, der sich einen eigenen Matrixer, das ist auch ein Messenger, der aber sozusagen
äh den man auch selber betreiben kann, ähm installierte Mustern auch so was machen?
Da steigt das natürlich eine schöne Steilvorlage zu den äh X tausend Gründen, warum das alles eine ziemlich schlechte Idee ist. Es ist tatsächlich aber relativ weit hinten. Also ich kann da gleich auch noch mal heraussagen, äh sagen, was eigentliche Problem ist, aber auch
Technisch muss man sagen, die haben sich vermutlich einfach keine Gedanken gemacht. Weil also uns sind schon ganz am Anfang bevor das Gesetz auch rausgekommen ist, haben wir überlegt, ey, was ist das eigentlich dann mit
also verschiedenste verschlüsselte Systeme, wie wollen die das da durchsetzen? Man hätte erwartet, dass es so was wie Ausnahmen für sehr kleine Plattformen gibt, Ausnahmen für privat betriebene Sachen, dass sich Leute Regeln überlegt haben für dezentrale Kommunikation.
Das ist alles nicht der Fall. Das wird mehr oder weniger in den Ermessensspielraum dieses EU-Zentrums übergeben, was dann aber völlig ohne
team demokratische Legitimation da entscheiden wird, was es, das heißt, das wissen wir nicht, was da genau passiert, aber das Gesetz befähigt erstmal zu wahnsinnig viel.
Und das ist das Problem. Aber jetzt finde ich eigentlich fast schwierig, dass wir einen sehr unwichtiges Problem,
Gesetz genannt haben, ohne die allerwichtigsten Probleme zu nennen, das würde ich jetzt vor kurz noch mal hinterherschießen, äh was eigentlich die wichtigen Probleme sind. Und zwar, es bringt überhaupt nichts
weil das nicht der Ort ist, an dem Kindesmissbrauchsabbildung geteilt werden. Also wir wissen jetzt schon. Wir müssen nicht mal sagen, die Leute werden das umgehen, sondern die Umgehungstechnik ist jetzt schon in Einsatz.
Weil jetzt schon wenn du sagst Umgehungstechnik, dann ja so als wären die Leute da und würden woanders hingehen.
Die es richtig verstanden habe.
Sind doch sozusagen Messenger gar nicht der Ort, wo so was passiert. Ich meinte mehr, die Technik, mit der man es umgehen würde, wenn man da wäre.
Genau. Ja. Was tatsächlich gerade mehr passiert oder was man weiß wenigstens ist, dass ähm aktuell werden diese werden die Links
zu solchen Inhalten werden in Darknet-Foren geteilt und,
dann wird einfach ein ähm wird ein Bild genommen. Das wird selber verschlüsselt und dann kann man das irgendwo hochladen. Einfach auf Google Cloud Dings hochladen, weil da kann dann auch kein Scanner mehr was dagegen tun, wenn es äh
von von der von vornherein schon verschlüsselt ist und das Passwort teilt man dann einfach in diesem Darkland Forum aus. Das ist das große Problem. So werden das Leute tun. So tun das auch Leute schon und da sind Scanner
völlig irrelevant. Da werden Messenger überhaupt nicht benutzt und deshalb es schießt einfach völlig am Problem vorbei und wird nichts verbessern.
Warte mal stopp. Erster Punkt. Was ist das Darknet?
Äh okay, muss ich jetzt ähm ja, wer sagt, pass auf, ne stopp! Ich ich will das jetzt nicht an der Stelle noch mal ausführlicher machen, weil ähm.
Wir
Im weitesten Sinne die technisch interessierten Menschen haben sich früher über diesen Begriff sehr lustig gemacht, ne? Uh das Darknet, da gibt's nur böse Sachen und so weiter und so fort. Das ist aber eine Diskussion mittlerweile so ein feststehender Begriff, ne
Also ich finde auch zurecht, aber trotzdem ist es glaube ich das nochmal an einer Stelle, wo man sagen muss, wenn man das sagt, was meint man denn damit? Mit das Darknet?
Wenn ich mich jetzt an einer Definition wage, würde ich mal sagen, das meint die Summe aller Internetseiten, die ausschließlich über ein sogenanntes
über das Tor Netzwerk erreichbar sind und das Tournetzwerk kennt man bei Menschen vielleicht den Tor Browser kennen, was ein Programm ist, das man sich runterladen kann und dann sehr anonym. Im Internet surfen kann und
Damit kommt man dann unter anderem,
auch auf diese Torwebseiten, die ähm nur aus dem, die sind dann teilweise nur aus dem Tor Netzwerk erreichbar.
Und eben in den Recht anonym, weil es da ein gewisses Protokoll gibt.
Mit dem man anonym bleibt. Aber ich ich will mal, ich will's mal umdrehen, ne, weil das jetzt hast du's mit einer ganz bestimmten Technologie äh verknüpft. Könnte man auch sagen, das Darknet ist der nichts äh nicht öffentlich zugänglicher Teil des Internets im Sinne von.
Es gibt sozusagen online Dinge, die kannst du nur erreichen, wenn du genau weißt, wo es ist und wie es geht.
Im Gegensatz zu, der Rest des Internets, der immer sozusagen
wenigstens scheinen oder teil öffentlich ist, ne. Also jede Webseite lässt sich googeln, jedes öffentlich geteilte Social Media Posting ist in irgendeinem Algorithmus drin und so weiter und so fort und es gibt aber eben auch Teile des Internets, die sind.
Da ist Tor sozusagen eine Möglichkeit und wahrscheinlich auch die verbreitete. Die sind quasi wie so gated communities.
Da kommt man halt nur rein, wenn man weiß, wo es ist. Genau, also das kann man sich, finde ich, immer ganz gut daran klarmachen, wie die,
URLs, die wir halt kennen, ähm aussehen. Ähm das sind halt.
Im Darknet sind es halt meistens lange wilde Kombinationen von Zahlen und Buchstaben und man kann nicht einfach nur so WWW.
Meine Plattform Punkt DE eingeben. Das würde halt nicht funktionieren. Deswegen muss man sehr genau wissen, wo die Dinge liegen, um das zu finden und das wird dann halt auch in keinem Listing von irgendeiner Suchmaschine auftauchen.
Wo ich jetzt vielleicht aber nochmal ergänzen würde, das ist ja durchaus Linklisten und Strukturen.
Für also für für Darknet Webseiten gibt. Also man kann sich das schon so vorstellen, dass es zum einen eine eine auch eine ganze Internetlandschaft gibt.
Im Darknet, die halt nur für Leute mit Tour Browser im Tor Netzwerk zur Verfügung gestellt werden und auf der anderen Seite gibt es dann auch noch mal Dienste, wo man
wo es gar keine Übersichten, die man gar nicht findet, sondern wo man genau die IP-Adresse wissen muss und jetzt ist mir gerade noch eingefallen, Bitorin ist vielleicht auch nochmal so ein
Zwischenfall betont, ich erklär's kurz. Ist ein äh Netzwerk, mit dem man sich Dateien schicken kann
was auch dezentral funktioniert, ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob es da so kohärente Diskussion ähm Definitionen gibt, aber ich glaube man kann auf jeden Fall sagen, das Internet ist mehr als das, was man auf Google findet.
Und technisch gesehen ist jetzt die Summe der Dinge, die die nur zugänglich sind,
wenn man gerade einen Tourbrowser benutzt, das ist relativ klar abtrennbar und da gibt es einfach eine Summe von Foren, von Seiten, von Informationsseiten, die sich
dir nur eröffnen, wenn du einen Turbobrowser benutzt
und die das ist gemacht dafür, dass da Leute eben anonym sind und dass es ähm auch keinen Server gibt, auf den man draufgucken kann.
Wer denn da jetzt genau grade zugegriffen hat und die Leute eben keine IP-Adresse haben.
Jetzt muss man sagen, das Problem ist sozusagen, da kann man auch in so einen abtauchen. Ich will's nur ganz kurz sagen, das ist auch was. Das hat auch seine Berechtigung.
Ne, also sagen ein ein Darknet, also im Sinne von einem nicht so leicht zugänglichen Netz, wo man relativ anonym kommunizieren will, hat viele Vorteile, wenn man zum Beispiel in einer Diktatur kommunizieren will, also die Deutsche Welle äh zum Beispiel
äh betreibt meines Wissens nach eine Webseite über Tor im Darknet sozusagen einfach, weil man die dann angucken kann ohne dabei erwischt zu werden von einer,
Internetüberwachung. So, aber da passieren halt auch diese Dinge und ich will jetzt wieder zurück zu unserem eigentlichen Thema kommen. Ähm Menschen, die
Kindesmissbrauchsmisshandlungen, Bilder davon teilen, äh tun das eben auch über eine Technologie, die Verschlüsselung, Anonymität et cetera et cetera erlaubt und
Da sind dann sozusagen, wenn überhaupt Messenger nur ganz am Ende der Kette.
Wenn überhaupt, ihr habt gesagt, das spielt eigentlich gar keine Rolle. Gibt's dazu irgendwie Studienerkenntnisse irgendwas? Also es gibt Ermittlungserfolge, die kann man halt anführen, also der bekannteste, da gibt's auch,
diverse Dokumentationen drüber ist dieser Fall, wo sie so ein ganzes Netzwerk hochgenommen haben. Mhm. Und der hat das halt sehr deutlich gezeigt, also diese Links- und Passwörter werden halt im Darknet
ausgetauscht
Grundsätzlich, weil das dann halt nicht nachverfolgbar ist und es ist auch sehr, sehr schwer in diese Gruppen aufgenommen zu werden. Also da muss man sehr viel Zeit drauf verwenden, sich da sozusagen einzuschleichen und dann
sind die Links und die Passwörter sozusagen
Im anderen Teil des Internet, das nennt man Clear web, also in einem an bei einem Hoster deiner Wahl, was auch immer es ist, wo man dann diese Daten verschlüsselt runterladen kann und sie dann halt mit dem Passwort.
Entschlüsseln kann und sich anschauen kann. Weil du jetzt gerade einschlägst und gesagt hast, liebe Leute, Don't trics at home.
Der Besitz von äh der Darstellung von Kindesmisshandlung ist auch zur Ermittlungszwecken, wenn man da, glaube ich, nicht irgendwie juristisch abgesichert ist, verboten und
höchst strafbar. Genau, das ist ganz wichtig, also das hat diese Steuerung F Recherche sehr gut gezeigt. Die konnten das nur machen, also.
Es gibt eine Recherche vom NDR und von Steuerung F. Ähm wo sie halt diverse.
Links aufgedeckt haben und zur Löschung bei Hosting Anbieterinnen gemeldet haben und dann denkt man
kann man so vereinfacht auf die Idee kommen und sagen, ach Mensch, cool wir Crowds-Hourcen das jetzt und dann löschen wir ganz viele ähm kinderpornographische Darstellungen aus dem Internet. Das wird so nicht funktionieren, weil das halt rechtswidrig ist.
Diesen Austausch oder auch die Anbahnung des Austausches vorzunehmen, also never christes at home please. Ja. So
Ähm also das heißt, wir haben also eine Motivation für ein Gesetz, die sich so gar nicht mehr halten lässt. So kann man's glaube ich abkürzen, ne. Also man sagt äh wir wollen also interpersonelle äh Kommunikation eingreifen und es stellt sich heraus, ja Moment mal,
äh in einem Rechtsgebiet, von dem ihr redet, spielt in der personelle Kommunikation nun eigentlich keine Rolle. Wenn man da ermitteln will, gibt es durchaus Ansätze, aber es sind eben nicht die Kommunikation aufzumachen.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle, glaube ich, nicht,
noch mal fragen, warum machen die das? Weil ich glaube, das hat mir in echt vielen, vielen verschiedenen Chaos-Radios auch schon. Es gibt einfach so ein sozusagen ein ein politisches Weltbild, dass Überwachung als etwas Gutes darstellt und es immer wieder versucht, immer wieder auch unter
Überspitzt Vortäuschung falscher Tatsachen. Ich möchte das jetzt irgendwie nicht justierbel zitiert haben, aber wenn man das politisch verfolgt, hat kann man schon den Eindruck,
bekommen, da laufen Dinge komisch. So, aber zurück zum aktuellen Beispiel, Chatkontrolle. Ähm.
Was ich ganz spannend finde ist der Name. Vielleicht könnt ihr den jetzt mal erklären, weil alles, was ihr bis jetzt erzählt habt, ist Folgendes.
In der EU gibt's Leute, die denken, ähm möglicherweise könnten wir das hier mal zum Anlass nehmen, auch wenn sie so ganz stimmt, aber egal zum Anlass nehmen ähm und überwachen jetzt intersonelle Kommunikation, interpersonelle Kommunikation, im Internet ist ja sehr viel mehr.
Als Messanging, also Chats. Warum heißt es in Chatkontrolle? Genau, also das ist ein.
Ein Begriff, den ähm Patrick Breier von der Piratenpartei im letzten Jahr geprägt hat, also dieses Gesetz,
steht schon relativ lange an, also es ist eine Verordnung und was man wissen muss dazu ist, es gibt schon eine Verordnung, die jetzt bald ausläuft, in der es.
Den Anbieterinnen erlaubt wird.
Unverschlüsselte Kommunikation auf solche Inhalte zu scannen und es sind halt.
Primär oder das Neue daran ist, dass jetzt auch Ende zu Verende Verschlüsselung betroffen ist und gescannt werden soll und dadurch kommt halt diese Prägung Chatkontrolle,
zustande dieser Entwurf an sich ist aber noch sehr, sehr, sehr viel mehr als Chatkontrolle.
Aber für wie soll ich sagen, für das breite Framing ist,
aus unserer Sicht die Chatkontrolle und dieser Angriff auf Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung das Schlimmste, was mit dieser Verordnung droht und deswegen wird das halt auch überall als Chatkontrolle.
Gefragt. Man muss aber dazu sagen, das ist nur in Deutschland so. Also dieser Begriff ist extrem von Patrick Breiers narrativ geprägt, weil der da halt schon über ein Jahr drüber spricht und eine Website hat und da hat alles erklärt.
In anderen EU-Ländern, ich habe mich da mit anderen Aktivisten in einem
digitale Rechtespektrum mal ausgetauscht, ist es überhaupt nicht so. Also das ist dann halt die Verordnung zum Schutz von Kindern online. So das ist so der der gängige Begriff. Das ist aber so total lang und da muss man immer sehr, sehr viel erklären
Chatkontrolle ist natürlich ein bisschen prägnanter an der Stelle. Aber am Ende lässt man trotzdem vehement dagegen.
Es ist also das muss man auch sagen in Deutschland würde man denkt man sich erstmal so boah das sieht voll gut aus es haben sich diverse Politikerinnen dagegen positioniert, es haben sich EU-Abgeordnete dagegen positioniert. In anderen Ländern schlägt das Ganze medial.
Nicht ganz so Wellen, also im deutschsprachigen Raum primär in Deutschland und Österreich.
Schlägt es ziemlich hohe Wellen durch CCC Digitalcourage, digitale Gesellschaft und in Österreich dann durch EpiCenter Works, die da sehr engagierte Medienarbeit machen. In anderen Ländern ist es schon so, dass die.
Datenschutzorganisation sich der Sache bewusst sind, die breiten Massen aber noch nicht so richtig darauf eingestiegen sind.
Genau, so kann man das glaube ich ganz gut sagen. Also wir werden diesen Kampf auch nur gewinnen, wenn wir's sozusagen schaffen, dieses,
narrativ diese Geschichte, die wir da in den deutschen Medien geprägt haben, auch in anderen EU-Ländern so zu prägen und auch Leute zu mobilisieren, auf die Straße zu gehen.
Dazu kann man vielleicht noch kurz ergänzen.
Dass das deshalb so wichtig ist. Also wir müssen da ordentlich Stimmung machen. Wenn jetzt alles so weiterläuft, wie es bisher aussieht, dann sieht es wirklich finster für uns aus.
Also das was jetzt viel passieren. Bevor wir die Sache anzünden ja müssen wir sie erklären. Also immer ne sozusagen zwei Drittel Heißöl, ein Drittel Benzin, alles klar, aber erst am Ende. Wenn so.
Ähm.
Wir sprechen später noch drüber, ne. Ich will nur, falls ich jetzt das jemand gerade frei habe, Moment mal, die reden jetzt irgendwie von Gesetzenverordnung, was auch immer, darüber sprechen wir auch gleich noch, ja? Also was ist eigentlich eine Verordnung? Aber jetzt noch mal Chatkontrolle. Was nicht unspannend ist, was nicht unspannend ist. Ähm.
Wenn man dass man verschlüsselte Kommunikation.
Zum Chat sozusagen hinschiebt, also dass man das als Bild nimmt, was da passiert, weil ich sage jetzt mal, einen Satz und ihr müsstet dann erklären, meine Macht als Moderator lässt du das machen und zwar Chats.
Oder Messenger sind tatsächlich die Niedrigwelt niedrigschwelligste Möglichkeit verschlüsselt zu kommunizieren. Wie ist das denn passiert?
Dass es eine großartige Entwicklung, die ich sehen würde als eine direkte Folge.
Der Snowdenenthüllungen. Du wirst fragen, was sind die Snowden-Enthüllungen? Ähm sind eine ähm das waren ähm äh Bekanntmachung, also ähm Edward Snowden ähm war ein ursprünglicher Geheimdienstmitarbeiter
der NSA und hat äh 213 gesagt, jo Leute, ich habe hier Material und das weiß ziemlich gut, dass ähm die Five, also die Geheimdienste von verschiedenen.
Westlichen Staaten das ganze Internet überwachen und das haben sie auch getan.
Das tun sie auch immer noch, aber ähm in in Folge daraus waren alle so wow, fuck, die wissen ja alles über uns und dann waren alle so okay, um uns davor zu schützen, müssen wir alles verschlüsseln und ähm in Folge davon fing das an, dass man zunehmend
angefangen hat.
Ähm Verkehr zu Internetseiten zu verschlüsseln, das kennt man vielleicht als das kleine grüne Schloss links oben. Wenn der harte TPS vor einer URL steht und
hat es auch angefangen, dass Leute ähm sogenannte Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Messenger Apps gebaut haben. Da ist ähm,
in meinen Recher, also da gibt es schon ganz viele Techniken, aber ich glaube, die ersten, wo das dann sehr bequem wurde, waren zum Beispiel Threema.
Und ähm was auch sehr viele kennen werden ist die ähm Messenger App Signal. Äh Threema wurde 2012 das Asthma vorgestellt, Signal 2tausendvierzehn, also alle so um diese
ja an der Stelle um das nochmal als Bild ganz klar zu machen. Weil ich finde es immer wieder, wenn man drüber nachging, total spannend, ne? Also,
Unterschied zwischen Darknet und äh sozusagen gesprochen. Mhm. Und.
Zieht euch das nochmal rein, liebe Hörerinnen. Es ist also nahegelegt und sozusagen sehr doll wahrscheinlich. Man kann's halt nie genau wissen, weil Geheimnisse, aber sozusagen von dem, was Noten uns da gesagt hat.
Alles. Literally, alles, was da draußen passiert, kann Teil einer Maschinerie sein. Ja, das wird also sagen, es ist,
unfassbar viel, aber all das und dazu zielt eben auch alle Kommunikation, die in diesem Internet stattfindet. Also es war ja früher sozusagen, keine Ahnung, äh ein Forum oder ein soziales Netzwerk. Wenn das nicht verschlüsselte Verbindungen hat.
Dann sind auch die sogenannten Direktnachrichten, ne, also wo man sich Leute einfach hin und her schreiben. All das
kann da drin an. Auch E-Mails, E-Mails, um's nur wirklich ganz kurz anzureißen. E-Mails sind letztlich Textdateien, die über verschiedene Rechner äh von Schief nach Schritte äh geschickt werden. Auch die können da drin sein.
Ja, das das war die schlechte das muss man sich mal rauernziehen und was ich nur noch kurz meinen Bogen zu Ende erzählen,
das hat verschiedene Leute und Communities motiviert entsprechende Dienste und Services zu bauen, in denen das eben nicht mehr geht. Also in denen man
Das Ziel ist, wir wir misstrauen unserem Internetanschluss und sagen, huh, keine Ahnung, was da passiert. Vielleicht läuft das ja ein Server von der NSA rein. Ich will jetzt aber trotzdem mit meinem Freund innen auf eine Art und Weise reden können, dass wir uns ziemlich sicher sind, dass die NSA
keine Ahnung hat, worüber wir geredet haben. Das war der Impuls und da kommt das alles her.
Befreie mich gerade so eine eine äh eine vielleicht etwas heritische Frage in diesem Umfeld ist, ob man der.
Der wirklich, also der wirklich weiten Verbreitung von Ende zu Ende verschüttete Kommunikation nicht WhatsApp zugute halten muss.
Also WhatsApp muss man sagen, war so ein bisschen lay to the Party. WhatsApp ist erst im Jahr 216,
Dazu kommen und benutzt im Prinzip genau den gleichen äh die gleiche Verschlüsselung wie Signal und.
Ich finde das sehr schwierig zu sagen.
Klar kann man da natürlich sagen, na ja, WhatsApp hatte eine Superbreite Userbasis. Ich glaube aber, es ist einigen auch einfach gar nicht aufgefallen.
Dass der Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung einfach einmal drinnen und es hat sie ja sozusagen die zwei Jahre die Signal vorher gab auch nicht davon abgehalten.
WhatsApp trotzdem zu benutzen. Also das ist ja wieder dieses klassische, ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen. Ähm ich glaube, dass das Bewusstsein in den letzten drei Jahren
gefühlt würde ich sagen
deutlich extremer geworden ist, weil jetzt ja nicht nur die Geheimdienste in diesem Spielfeld mitspielen, sondern auch
große Konzerne wie Facebook und Co die halt auch gerne Daten absaugen möchten für wirtschaftliche Interessen
und dadurch kommt halt auch eine erhöhte Sensibilisierung von Menschen zustande, die sagen, okay,
also eigentlich möchte ich nicht, dass du ein großes Unternehmen aus meinen Daten Geld macht und irgendwie mein ganzes User-Verhalten absaugt und.
Deswegen sind viele Menschen, glaube ich, an sicherer Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung.
Interessierter, als sie's vielleicht vorher gewesen wären. Ja. Und ich würde jetzt auch die steile These aufstellen, dass äh,
so Konzerne wie Facebook oder Meta heißen die ja heute, dass die nichts machen, weil sie gute Menschen sind, sondern vermutlich das gemacht haben, weil sie gefürchtet haben, es könnte irgendwie ein Plattformnachteil entstehen oder sowas, aber ich glaube ähm also.
Die als allerletztes äh sind sonst ja durch besonders äh
Datenschutz äh positives Verhalten aufgefallen und äh ich würde auch tippen, sie dachten so, na ja, okay, bevor das jetzt einfach mega miese Presse gibt, machen wir's einfach. Die Inhalte wollen wir eh nicht haben. Wer mit wem kommuniziert, wissen wir trotzdem.
Ähm oder aber natürlich hat das im Endeffekt hat das dazu geführt.
Dass die ähm Anzahl der NutzerInnen in Deutschland die Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt kommunizieren, sicherlich gestiegen ist. Bedanken möchte ich mich jetzt aber trotzdem nicht bei Ihnen.
Nee, genau. Das kann ich nachvollziehen. Kann man so sagen, das ist das ist eine interessante Entwicklung, ne. Also einerseits Verschlüsselung ist für die, die es wollen, relativ leicht zugänglich.
Und andererseits sozusagen einen Großteil der Userbase. Ich habe jetzt die aktuellen WhatsApp-Zahlen nicht dabei, aber das ist ja wirklich ähm.
Sich jenseits von Gut und Böse 80 Prozent oder so was, also das ist einfach sehr weit verbreitet. Das das passiert Leuten. Also Leute kommunizieren verschlüsselt, ohne es zu wissen sozusagen. Das kann tatsächlich äh auch passieren. Das heißt, wir leben in einer Welt, wo eine Verschlüsselung möglich ist.
Müssen wir, glaube ich, noch einmal ganz kurz sagen in eurem Feldzug.
Habt es geschafft zu erklären, was Verschlüsselung überhaupt ist. Also dieses Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung. Das haben wir schon oft gemacht, aber ich will's immer wieder versuchen. Kann man das kurz erklären?
Ich denke schon, also ich kann ja mal anfangen und Viktor macht weiter. Also.
Ich finde irgendwie immer ja ähm also ich möchte Viktor jetzt eine Nachricht schicken.
Und ich möchte, dass Markus davon nichts mitbekommt.
So. Jetzt hast du vorhin schon gesagt, so dass E-Mails versenden, so ein bisschen ist wie Podcast Postkarten durchs Internet zu schicken. Da kann jeder mitlesen und.
Das heißt Viktor und ich brauchen jetzt eine Möglichkeit unsere Nachricht sozusagen so.
Zu manipulieren, dass außer ihm und mir niemand anders weiß, was inhaltlich dadrin steht.
So, dann müssen wir nämlich nicht dem Übertragungsmedium, also in diesem Fall dem Internet, Vertrauen.
Sondern können einfach da alles reinschreiben, was wir wollen.
Das verschlüsseln, also das so manipulieren, dass niemand anders weiß, was da drin steht und dann miteinander austauschen.
Ganz grundsätzlich. Jetzt kann man da technisch noch ein bisschen tiefer einsteigen.
Habe ja gesagt, manipulieren, manipulieren heißt, dass wir da irgendwie einen Algorithmus drauf anwenden müssen, damit dieses Datenpaket sich verändert und.
Da kann man auch unterschiedlich arbeiten.
Wir haben ja das Wort Verschlüsselung, das heißt, wir haben wahrscheinlich einen Schlüssel, um das Ganze zu manipulieren.
Und Viktor braucht auch einen Schlüssel.
Um das Ganze wieder zu entschlüsseln. Es ist das irgendwie doof, wenn wir beide den gleichen Schlüssel haben und derjenige, der uns den Schlüssel klaut.
Das mitlesen kann. Obwohl man sagen muss, da geht es jetzt macht sich das Feld auf. Also es gibt verschiedene
Arten, wie man das jetzt leisten könnte. Vielleicht noch mal kurz als Veranschaulichung. Wir beide sitzen in verschiedenen Gefängniszellen. Du bist unser Gefängnis wert und befinden dich beide doof. Wir finden also und jetzt ist unser Ziel, wie können wir miteinander reden, ohne dass du,
mitkriegst, worüber wir geredet haben. So und das und das ist jetzt ein sehr abstraktes Problem. Da kann man jetzt Mathematik drauf werfen.
Da gäbe es jetzt zum Beispiel einmal die Möglichkeit, dass wir vielleicht Sichtkontakt haben in unseren Gefängniszellen und uns entweder mit Rauchzeichen und mit Fingerzeichen irgendwie einen gemeinsamen Schlüssel zu morsen können.
Und ähm dann gibt es, wie gesagt, das sind alles Mathespielereien, beliebig komplizierte Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen, wie wir's dann schaffen können, werden wir beide vorher einen gemeinsamen Schlüssel ausgemacht haben,
Nachricht so zu verschlüsseln, dass du, selbst wenn du ganz schön viel Zeit hast, nicht drauf kommst, was da eigentlich drin stand,
Wenn wir jetzt irgendwie anfangen zu sagen, unser Schlüssel ist drei, was bedeutet, dass wir jeden Buchstaben Alphabet drei weiter zählen, dann brauchst du halt vielleicht eine halbe Stunde mit einem Stift und einem Papier und dann hast du's rausgekriegt.
Und die richtig coolen, aktuellen Verschlüsselungselsagorithmen, die sind mehr so, wenn der Schlüssel ausreichend lang ist, dass du so Millionen bis Milliarden Jahre bräuchtest. Um es rauszukriegen, selbst wenn du mega den krassen Computer hast.
Und das ist dann ziemlich cool, weil so viel Zeit wirst du nicht haben und wenn ja, dann ist die Welt eh schon kaputt. Also die Erde und aber ich weiß, was ihr gesagt habt. Ähm genau und das ist so ein bisschen das Ziel und jetzt ist aber,
viel von Verschlüsselungen scheitert immer an der Schlüsselverteilung. Also werden jetzt in unserem Fall hatten wir den sehr.
Bequemen Fall, dass wir zwei Gefängniszellen mit Sichtkontakt hatten, da konnten wir dann über Rauchzeichen oder Spiegelgemausse konnten wir uns auf einen Schlüssel einigen. Angenommen, wir sitzen jetzt auf äh verschiedenen Kontinenten oder Inseln, dann geht das natürlich nicht mehr.
Und das ist ein Problem, weil wenn wir nur dich als unseren verhassten, unvertrauenswürdigen Kanal haben, dann können wir uns ja nicht.
Ohne Weiteres so schon auf einen gemeinsamen Schlüssel einigen? Da gibt es dann natürlich trotzdem wieder technische Spielereien, wie das äh dann doch geht,
aber äh selbst wenn wir das jetzt könnten, wäre dann natürlich für mich auch wieder ein großes Problem. Wie kriege ich denn jetzt überhaupt raus, dass Kalisi tatsächlich Khalisi ist?
Und nicht du, Kallisi wirst und du sagst, ja komm, wir einigen uns jetzt auf einen gemeinsamen Schlüssel. Also wir merken, es ist alles ein bisschen kompliziert. Ähm es gibt aber verschiedene Ansätze und zum Beispiel die,
E-Mail-Verschlüsselung klärt das dann so, dass man sagt, es gibt irgendwann zentrales Register von Schlüsseln.
Und dann wird ein besonders cooler Kniff der Verschlüsselung und zwar die asymmetrische Verschlüsselung benutzt.
Da haben wir nicht mehr den gleichen Schlüssel, sondern gibt es zwei Schlüssel und ich kann Khalisi eine Nachricht schicken,
und ich muss nur so was wie ihre Visitenkarte gehabt haben. Sie hat ihren privaten kleinen Schließfachschlüssel und mit ihrem Schließfachschlüssel kann sie Material entschlüsseln, was ich ihr geschickt habe, während ich es mit ihrer, nennen wir's mal Visitenkarte geschickt habe.
Und dann ist das alles ganz schick. Ich weiß nicht, in welchen Umfängen äh du jetzt ähm,
ich glaube halt tatsächlich dieses dieses asrimitische Verschlüsselung. Ich glaube, das ist immer der Knackpunkt, um es Menschen zu erklären, die die keine Vorstellung davon haben und da da bin ich bis jetzt noch jedes Mal dran gescheitert, weil man muss immer Vergleiche nehmen, die hinken, ne, also sowas wie es gibt eine Kiste.
Und für die gibt es zwei Schlüssel und wenn man sie mit dem einen zuschließt, kann man sie nur mit dem anderen aufschließen und umgedreht.
So, dann muss man irgendwie muss man aber sozusagen wissen, welcher Schlüssel das jetzt war und so weiter und so fort. Das ist als als Bild immer schwierig, aber wir können's äh können's vielleicht dabei belassen. Was ich ganz spannend finde, ist Folgendes. Ähm.
Es gibt eben dieses dieses Konzept der asymmetrischen Verschlüsselung und es gibt es schon sehr lange und das gibt es auch in.
Sagen wir mal, beliebige Werte von benutzbar benutzbar für Mehlprogramme. Trotzdem hat sich das nicht durchgesetzt.
Und jetzt haben wir aber gerade ja festgestellt, der Moment mal, es gibt in dem Messenger Millionen von Menschen nutzen die und da funktioniert's einfach. Was ist denn der Unterschied? Also ich glaube, der Unterschied ist, dass den Userinnen da sehr viel abgenommen wird. Also.
Warum Leute vielleicht keine E-Mail-Verschlüsselung.
Verwenden hat mehrere Faktoren, weil ich muss mir dann erstmal meine Schlüssel generieren, ich muss wissen, wie ich den Schlüssel auf diesen Keyserver bekomme und ich muss dann wissen, wie ich welchen Schlüssel ich meinem Kommunikationspartner schicken,
muss. Ich darf meinen privaten Schlüssel nicht verlieren. Das Problem kennen irgendwie alle so Privatschlüssel verlieren. Das äh passiert.
Auch den besten Technikern ab und an ähm.
So. Es ist alles super kompliziert. Es ist überhaupt nicht userfreundlich. Ähm es ist jetzt inzwischen in vielen ähm.
Mailprogramm integriert und dann geht das auch ein bisschen einfacher, aber ich glaube, das ist grundsätzlich das Ding.
Wenn wir jetzt aber zum Beispiel Signal hernehmen, dann lade ich mir Signal runter, lege mir da einen Account an und dann funktioniert's. So, ich muss dafür nichts mehr machen.
Und das Ganze ist dann ähm Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt. Genau.
Ähm heißt das aber, dass die Verschlüsselung bei Messenger weniger sicher ist.
Einfach so funktioniert?
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist da kann man sich auch ähm äh stark reinwerfen. Jedes Verschlüsselungs- und ähm Kommunikationssystem, was anonym und sicher kommunizieren, ermöglichen soll, hat immer Annahmen und hat immer Kompromisse.
Und ähm Signal macht zum Beispiel jetzt die Annahme beziehungsweise den Kompromiss
indem sie sagen, na ja, wir gehen mal davon aus, dass das erste Mal, was du wenn du mit einer Person eine Nachricht schreibst, dass das schon die echte Person sein wird und nicht die Falsche.
Und das das nennt diese Annahme nennt man Tofu das heißt das erste Mal vertrauen wir der Sache und dann gehen wir davon aus dass das Vermutlich schon geklappt hat. Ähm bei E-Mail-Verschlüsselung funktioniert das zum Beispiel nicht so dabei wäre es jetzt.
Also das ist immer eine Frage von wie sicher sicher soll es sein und wo findet man eine gute Kompromiss zwischen Benutzbarkeit und Sicherheit und ich glaube,
diesen Messenger haben aber einen ziemlich guten Kompromiss gefunden und
Es gibt bei Signal aber trotzdem die Möglichkeit, um herauszufinden, ob die andere Person denn jetzt tatsächlich die Person ist, von der man es glaubt. Und zwar werden sogenannte Safety-Nummer, so Sicherheitsnummern angezeigt und die kann man vergleichen und gucken, ob das die gleiche ist und wenn das die gleiche ist,
dann ist alles prima, plus noch cooler, kann man tatsächlich mit dem eigenen Signal-Handy ein Foto von der fremden Sicherheitsnummer machen und dann sagen die beiden Handys
jetzt hast du's überprüft, weil dann hat man wie so einen zweiten Kanal, das jetzt wieder der Sichtkontakt zwischen unseren beiden Gefängniszellen. Wenn der auf einmal besteht, dann haben wir einen zweiten, sicheren Kanal
auf dem wir sicherstellen können, hey, wir sind wirklich
die zwei Personen, die gerade miteinander kommunizieren und nicht, dass du zu mir sagst, du bist Khalisi und dass du zu Khalisi sagst, du bist Viktor. Und ein ganz wichtiger Hinweis, weil ich glaube, die meisten Leute haben das auch schon gesehen. Also man sieht häufiger mal in so Gruppen-Chats, sowohl bei WhatsApp als auch bei Signal, dass ich von irgendjemand die Safety-Nummer geändert hat.
Mhm. Und eigentlich müsste man jedes Mal, wenn man wirklich sicherer kommunizieren möchte, wenn man diese Meldung kriegt.
Kontakt zu dieser Person aufnehmen und sagen, hey, deine Sicherheitsnummer hat sich geändert. Wir müssen uns jetzt treffen.
Einmal abgleichen, um zu gucken, ob das wirklich noch du bist. Also das ist nämlich ein Indikator dafür, dass da irgendwas passiert ist. Mhm. Also in der Regel ist es dann ein neues Handy, ne.
Ja, genau. Also es ist in der Regel total unproblematisch, aber es ist, denke ich, trotzdem gut zu wissen, dass es diesen Mechanismus gibt und ich glaube, es machen auch die wenigsten, dass die sich dann noch mal die Safety-Nummer abgleichen zum Beispiel. Also das ist.
Das ist da sind wir ja oft sozusagen in der Spur einer interessanten gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung, weil das funktioniert ja, wenn wir's jetzt praktisch ansehen über Plausibilität.
Weil wenn nicht sozusagen, wenn ich ähm keine Ahnung Beispiel von Fend, wenn ich in einer Diktatur bin, wo ich Angst um mein Leben haben muss.
Würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht zu irgendeiner Signal äh zu irgendeiner Telefonnummer, die mir gegeben hat, schreiben und dann davon ausgehen, na ja gut, wenn er jetzt gegenüber schreibt, nicht grad nicht im selben Raum, aber würde schon irgendwie stimmen. Aber für unseren Alltag geht das natürlich.
Also wenn mir irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung. Danimo aus dem Chaosradioteam eine Nummer gibt und sagt, die ist von Viktor und dann gebe ich dir mein Signal ein und dann äh antwortet da jemand und,
wir unterhalten uns sozusagen wie Viktor und rufen uns an vielleicht sozusagen, ähm dann ist es halt relativ plausibel, dass jetzt wirklich eine verschlüsselter Kontakt zusammengekommen ist. Und an der Stelle.
Ist sozusagen
Nachteil und der Unterschied zu E-Mail, ne? Also die E-Mail-Verschlüsselung ist tatsächlich von der Usability so gestaltet, dass sie davon ausgeht, nee, wenn du's nicht sichergestellt hast, dann mache ich's dir auch eher schwer, dass ihr euch verschlüsselt kommuniziert. Und der Effekt von dieser Plausibilität ist aber,
von dieser Prüfung in Anführungszeichen ist, dass wir eben ganz viel verschlüsselt kommunizieren, das heißt
Im Eins-zu-Eins-Fall kann das immer noch irgendwie komisch sein, ne, also wie gesagt, wenn man sein Leben drauf verwetten muss, dass das funktioniert, würde man das noch mal komplizierter machen.
Aber das heißt eben, unsere Standardkommunikationswege ist doch einmal verschlüsselt und das heißt und da sind wir bei der Sache, bei der mit der du vorhin angefangen hattest, Viktor, dann sind wir bei Snowden, ne? Es ist eben nicht mehr so einfach.
Anlasslos einfach alle Kommunikationsdinge äh mitzuschneiden. Du wolltest gerade was sagen Viktor?
Äh ich wollte nur kurz ergänzen, dass das vielleicht auch mehr einfache Designschwierigkeiten sind, dass das bei E-Mail nicht geht. Theoretisch, wenn es einen gemeinsamen Server oder ein gemeinsames Protokoll gäbe, könnten sich ja auch zwei E-Mail-Adressen sagen, ja
cool Dicke, du wirst vermutlich der sein, von dem du sagst, dass du bist, lass mal Schlüssel tauschen und lass mal hier einen verschlüsselten Kanal bauen. Das tun die Dinger halt nicht
bei E-Mail weil es nicht diese dezentralen Server gibt, die sich konkret über um Verschlüsselung kümmern und faktisch gesehen, also wie das mit den Keyservern gedacht ist, lädt man sich da auch
irgendeinen Schlüssel runter und das Sicherheitskonzept ist dann ja eigentlich, dass dir jemand eine Visitenkarte gegeben haben muss, wo der Fingerprint draufsteht und das tut sowieso niemand und das hat einfach die die Praxis gezeigt, dass das leider
alles etwas kompliziert ist und genau da nimmt dir Signal einige Schritte davon ab.
Und wenn du tatsächlich die Sicherheitsnummern verglichen hast, dann bist du dir auch sicher, dass es die andere Person ist.
Jetzt funktioniert ja äh könnte man jetzt sagen, das ist auch ein Erfolg, das es gibt ja immer dieses Buy Design, ne. Also man sagt irgendwie Plattform soll mit Datenschutz beide sein oder eben Kommunikationsmittel sollen Secure by Design sein.
Ist es oder Privacy bei Design? Ist das sozusagen quasi ein Erfolg? Frage ich mich jetzt gerade, weil E-Mail ist ja zu sagen, es gab erst E-Mail.
Dann hat on top jemanden eine Möglichkeit entwickelt, wie das verschlüsselt ist und Messenger wie
Threema, Signal oder jetzt irgendwie auch das Matrix äh das Matrix System? Sind ja entwickelt worden.
Mit sozusagen von Grund auf mit der Grundannahme, wir wollen Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation möglich machen. Glaubt ihr, das ist ein Unterschied oder ist es eher so ein Glückstreffer? Ich glaube, das ist eher so ein Glückstreffer, weil bei WhatsApp haben sie's ja zum Beispiel auch nachrüsten können.
Ne? Aber das das ging ja das ging aber nur, weil's ein zentralisiertes System ist, ne? Ja Problem bei E-Mail ist ja sozusagen
Das ist ja, es gibt ja nicht den einen E-Mail-Betreiber, sondern ganz viele verschiedene Server und deswegen konnte man's und es gab schon ganz viel Software und WhatsApp hatte halt den Vorteil sozusagen, das wird auf einer zentralen, also das ist nicht ein Server, aber es wird auf einer zentralen Infrastruktur betrieben und es wird die,
die Benutzungssoftware wird zentral auch ausgeliefert.
Ja, das würde ich auch sagen. Das ist ein großer Unterschied. Es wird viel einfacher, wenn man selber der Server ist und wenn man alle Clients kontrolliert, also wenn auch alle Cliants gleich sind und es nicht so ein sehr offenes System ist, wo alle vielleicht auch ein bisschen was anderes machen.
Und ja, deshalb würde ich sagen, wird es dir da sehr einfach gemacht. Und jetzt muss man bei noch sagen,
ähm die sind ja also Signal, da ist das ja in den Kern. Das das Signal Protokoll heißt Signal Protokoll da ist das wirklich in den Kern eingebaut gewesen, ne? Also bei WhatsApp wurde das nachgerüstet. Signal ist ja gestartet mit dem Ziel.
Ein Ende zu Ende verschlüsselten Messenger zu bauen. Du wolltest grad noch? Alles gut. Okay.
Das heißt aber, das heißt also, wenn wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, was ist denn das beste Beispiel, müsste man eigentlich sagen, das ist Matrix, ne, weil das sozusagen eben nicht, weil weil da ist wirklich nur das Protokoll, es ist dezentral wirklich aber gut. Andere Diskussion, lasst uns zurück zur Chatkontrolle kehr.
Weil die nächste Etappe sozusagen ein bisschen erklärt, ne, also wir reden über diese EU-Verordnung, wir
klären später noch, was eine Verordnung ist. Ähm wir haben jetzt erklärt, also warum das irgendwie relevant ist oder wogegen sich das richtet. Und jetzt finde ich hier der spannende Punkt ist, es gab ja in der Vergangenheit eigentlich, wenn so was anstand, immer die Versuche, die Verschlüsselung aufzuweichen.
Ne, also eher so was wie zu sagen aha ihr kommuniziert Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, könnt ihr vielleicht auch einen Schlüssel bei uns hinterlegen?
Ähm oder so zentrale Anbieter zu sagen, ja, also wenn ihr euren Leuten das irgendwie ermöglicht, dann vielleicht könnt ihr ja.
Und das hat man ja und das finde ich vielleicht könnte man fast schon eine positive Nachricht, das hat man ja aufgegeben. Nee, wir kommen gleich dazu, sozusagen wie das jetzt ein neuer anderer Angriff ist.
Aber Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung wird doch erstmal nicht in Frage gestellt oder?
Also ich würde bei meinem Jein bleiben. Okay. Um ehrlich zu sein. Ähm prinzipiell was du sagst ist richtig ähm.
Also ich glaube, die Gesetzgeberinnen haben gemerkt, dass wenn sie, immer wenn sie mit diesem äh Verschlüsselung mit.
Backdoors. Ähm ich glaube, es ist sicher eine Sicherheit durch und trotz Verschlüsselung ist ja so dieser famose Satz, den wir mal von der EU-Kommission gehört haben. Ähm anfangen, dann wird es sozusagen sofort abgeschmettert,
mit Argumenten, von Privatsphäre, Sicherheit und Angst vor mehr Überwachung.
So und man kann's sozusagen sagen, die Gesetzgeberinnen haben gelernt, dass sie damit nicht so gut Überwachungsmaßnahmen durchsetzen können. Mhm. Und
Deswegen schreiben Sie sich sozusagen jetzt ganz groß auf die Plan.
Wir können das trotzdem alles machen, ohne eure Hände zu verändern, Verschlüsselung zu gefährden.
Und haben dann diesen schönen Begriff von einer Technologie neutralen Gesetzgebung in ihrem.
In ihrer Verordnung in diesem Fall und können dann sagen, ja ne, ne, aber.
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung greifen wir gar nicht an. Anders herum schreiben sie aber auch nicht rein, das Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung explizit geschützt werden muss. Das sollte man an der Stelle immer im Hinter im Hinterkopf behalten.
Ähm so, jetzt ist er aber sozusagen die und dann können wir jetzt vielleicht tatsächlich zur Umsetzung kommen. Jetzt ist er aber das, also es steht ja nicht drin, wie es geplant ist, aber es gibt ja sozusagen,
Die Expertinnen sagen ja okay, wenn ihr das so umsetzen wollt, dann gibt es genau einen technischen Weg, wie man das machen kann,
ohne die Ende zu einer Verschlüsselung aufzuweichen. Vielleicht könnt ihr den jetzt mal skizzieren. Genau soll da passieren. Ja also dazu äh noch mal ganz kurz etwas
bisschen grundlegenderes. Dazu komme ich gleich, aber ähm ich glaube, es ist äh nochmal gut drüber nachzudenken, dass es gibt, wieso.
Vier Szenarien angenommen, ich habe ein mathematisch solides Verschlüsselungsmodell, ne? Also es gibt eigentlich fünf Arten, wie man 5 Grundarten, wie man an verschlüsselte Kommunikation rankommt.
Grund eins, du hast im Sinne von nicht, wie man sie umsetzen kann, sondern Sicherheitsbehörde mit Inhalte mit lesen kann. Grund eins, es gibt eine mathematische Schwachstelle in der Kryptographie,
diese Verschlüsselungstechnik und deshalb gibt es irgendeine Abkürzung wie man es besonders schnell schafft Schlüssel zu erraten und das Ding trotzdem.
Entschlüsseln kann. Das wollen wir eigentlich nicht. Das wenn man das äh vorschreiben würde, dann würde man eigentlich echte Verschlüsselung verbieten und da haben mittlerweile die irgendwie gelernt, okay, das ist jetzt irgendwie das ist es nicht, ähm.
Das wäre auch extrem gefährlich, weil, wie gesagt, Schwachstellen gibt's nicht. Hintertüren gibt's nicht immer nur für die guten. Die gibt's auch für die Bösen. Und das würde einfach auch sämtliche
Geheimdienst, Geheimnisse und Unternehmensgeheimnisse und alle Geheimnisse, die wir als Gesellschaft haben, alle gefährden. Und dann gibt es vier. Wenn wir das nicht wollen, dann gibt es vier weitere Arten und Weisen, wie wir an diese Kommunikation rankommen können.
Das ist die erste Art, dass ich einen Trojaner auf dem Gerät installiere. Daher kommt die Staatstrojaner Idee, weil die Leute gesagt haben, okay.
Wir können jetzt gar nicht mehr im Internet überwachen, na da müssen wir erinnern, die Geräte. Und das war die Idee, die ja auch völlig höhnrissig ist, von wir installieren einen Trojan auf den Geräten, der damit trotzdem furchtbar rechtssicher und überhaupt nicht fälschbar äh die Kommunikation mitschneidet,
In der Praxis könnte der aber irgendwas am Gerät manipulieren, weil der halt tief dick in dem Handy sitzen muss.
Ich will ja nicht sagen, dass es dazu ein Chaosradio gibt, aber ich würde nur Wetten Song. Ja, ja, genau, alles so. Es gibt ähm die nächste Sache ist, Brutforce, also wenn man ausreichend viel
Zeit hat und ausreichend viel Kapazität.
Kann man theoretisch, besteht bei jedem Verschlüsselungssystem theoretisch die Möglichkeit alle möglichen Schlüssel durchzuraten und einfach zu warten, bis der Richtige rauskommt.
Wenn das Verschlüsselungssystem aber.
Solide gebaut ist, dann dauert das Millionen bis Milliarden Jahre, deshalb ist das dann oft sehr unpraktikabel, aber also diese theoretische Möglichkeit gibt es auch immer und das Letzte, was immer geht.
Ist ähm dass man sagt, okay dass man die App auf dem Gerät, bevor die Verschlüsselung passiert, die zwingt, guck dir den Inhalt an und das ist das, was hier passiert. Wenn du etwas Kleinzeit-Scanning.
Also Client sei geräteseitiges Überprüfen, kontrollieren, scannen, von Inhalten.
Und deshalb äh äh kann man also wir sind da irgendwann mal drauf gekommen, eigentlich ist das ähm wenn man so möchte, ein Kai basierter Massenstartstrojan, aber das das Gleiche macht wie der Staatstrojaner, aber es kriegen nicht nur einzelne Leute, sondern es kriegen alle Leute.
Und das Ding überlegt ähm detektiert, KI basiert, ob den jetzt eine Nachricht ausgeleitet werden soll oder nicht.
Der Reihe nach, bitte. Also. Was genau passiert da auf dem Gerät? Genau. Kleinside scanning.
Vielleicht erinnern sich einige von euch an die Debatte, die wir im letzten Jahr mit Apple hatten.
Apple hat nämlich schon mal angefangen sowas zu bauen und so der der große Werbespruch war halt, dass sie dabei weiterhin die ähm.
Privatsphäre ihrer Userinnen sicherstellen können. Was ist gleichzeitig also? Viktor hat ja schon gesagt, das passiert irgendwie vorher auf dem Gerät.
Und wir müssen natürlich, damit es vorher auf dem.
Gerät passieren können, paar Voraussetzungen schaffen. Also erst mal müssen wir, wenn wir's jetzt ganz einfach machen,
Also suchen nach bekannten Materialien müssen wir irgendwas haben, wogegen wir das prüfen können. Das heißt.
Man hat eine Datenbank mit Bildhes, also Hashes, die aus Bildern.
Was ist dein Hashtag? Du hast nur darauf gewartet, dass ich jetzt auch mal dran bin. Also ein Hash ist im Prinzip ein Algorithmus.
Der auf ein Bild angewandt wird und das wird dann halt.
Wie eine Funktion, das heißt es wird auf was angewandt, am Ende kommt was raus, das hat auch immer die gleiche Länge, eine festgelegte Länge, genau.
Und dadurch hat man nicht das Problem einen Fingerabdrücken also was ich was ich gerne über sage ist ähm.
Alle alle digitalen Daten sind ja Zahlen letztlich und man kann auf digitale Daten Mathe rauf werfen und dann kommt ein eindeutiger Wert drauf.
Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn man was reinwirft und da kommt hinten derselbe Wert raus, ist man kann man relativ sicher sein, dass man vorne wieder dasselbe reingeworfen hat.
Genau. Das ist eine viel bessere Erklärung als meine. Ich wollte jetzt ganz genau. So, was heißt das also? Wir haben also diese.
Datenbank und wir müssten dann auf unserem Gerät, also wenn ich jetzt an Viktor zum Beispiel ein Bild schicken möchte, würde dieses Bild.
Auf meinem Gerät gehasht werden und es würde geschaut werden, ob in dieser Bilddatenbank.
Dieser Hash schon liegt und wenn ja, würde das als verdächtiges Material ähm markiert werden und dann entsprechend ausgeleitet werden.
Also an Ermittlungsbehörden weitergeleitet. Es wird automatisch dahingeschickt werden. Genau.
Aber das hört sich doch erstmal gar nicht so schlecht an eigentlich. Ja, aber also es gibt mehrere Dinge, die man da bedenken muss. Erst mal.
Würde das heißen, dass wirklich alles erstmal abgeglichen werden muss. So und.
Wer die Macht über diese Datenbank hat, hat auch die Macht dadrüber, was weitergeleitet wird, also
weitergeleitet, nicht an meinen Kommunikationspartner, sondern weitergeleitet an die entsprechende Behörde, die diese ganze Geschichte überwacht, so.
Okay. Vielleicht könnte man noch also einsteigen und sagen, also erst das Einzige, das Wichtigste ist ja eigentlich, das Ding ist völlig unwirksam, weil das völlig an Problemen vorbei ist. Das 2 Ding ist, dass es gefährlich, weil es erstens nicht praktikabel ist,
die wenigen Kindesmissbrauchsabbildungen überhaupt zu finden, weil jetzt kann man sich überlegen, wie wie tut man das, entweder man sagt, wir suchen bekanntes Material.
Äh dann dann muss man irgendwo eine Liste haben von allen bekannten Kindesmissbrauchsabbildungen oder man sagt,
Wir machen das, wir bauen da eine zauberhafte KI, die dazu in der Lage ist, aber auch die wird Fehler machen. Aber wir wollten ja jetzt erstmal grundsätzlich nur bei Kleinzeit Scanning bleiben, sondern ich hat und noch keinen Abstecher über alles machen, deswegen sage ich
bekannten Material aus grundsätzlich, was ist Kleinzeit-Scanning und was ist das Problem?
So genau, das das habe ich jetzt definitiv verstanden, weil äh wenn man von diesen Werten ausgeht ähm die sind ja relativ genau das heißt ähm.
Ich würde.
Man würde sagen also gutes Gerät rechnet also diesen Wert auf, das passiert auch nur bei mir auf dem Gerät äh und erst wenn ich da wirklich exakt dasselbe Bild habe wie in der Dartbank hinterlegt ist, dann ähm.
Dann wird das ausgeheilt. So jetzt gibt's jetzt gibt's zwei Möglichkeiten von Missbrauch, die ich mir da vorstellen kann. Die will ich jetzt erstmal abfragen. Das eine ist ähm es hat ja.
In der Vergangenheit auch so Einzelfälle gegeben, ne, also irgendwie Polizisten nutzten Datenbanken, um Personen XY zu stalken.
Ist das was, was man auch hier sozusagen nimmt? Also irgendjemand äh macht ein Hashtag in die Daten, Hashtag in die Datenbank und sagt, hier schickt mir mal schickt mir mal das dieses sexy Bild von diesem Blumentopf.
Oder ist das eher hier kein Problem, das gesehen wird? Also,
wenn wir uns das Gesetz anschauen, ist es halt so, dass diese Behörde grundsätzlich an Europol angegliedert wird und.
Mehr weiß man noch nicht genau, also die wird jetzt auch schon aufgebaut im Hintergrund, ähm obwohl dieser.
Diese Verordnung noch gar nicht durch ist und.
Ich glaube, dass Miss, also ich persönlich würde grundsätzlich erstmal das Missbrauchspotential höher einschätzen, wenn es um.
Politische Dinge geht, also zum Beispiel das beste Beispiel ist glaube ich ein Demoaufruf. Wenn ich rausfinden will,
wer alles auf eine Demo gehen wird oder wenn ich Bilder einfach ausm europäischen Raum verschwinden lassen will, weil wenn das ausgeleitet wird, wird es halt entsprechend.
Oder kann das auch entsprechend gesperrt werden. So. Das heißt, das ist nämlich das Höchste mit Bundesbrauspotential. Ich kann halt einfach dafür sorgen, dass bestimmte Bilder einfach gar nicht mehr im europäischen Rechtsraum,
auftauchen würden und dadurch halt ganze Dinge unterbinden sozusagen, ne.
Ähm was jetzt natürlich schon so eine, das ist ein Mist mögliches Missbrauchsszenario, würde ich sagen, ne? Also das steht so im Gesetzesentwurf nicht drin. Ähm,
ich vielleicht aber noch sagen würde, eigentlich geht es ja ums vertrauenswürdige Kommunikation. Also wenn ich Kalesi eine Nachricht schreibe, dann möchte ich wirklich sicher sein, dass ich vertrauen kann,
dass die nur bei ihr Land, dass sie bei ihr landet und zwar nur bei ihr landet
Und das Problem an Kleinzeitscanne ist jetzt, dass ich meinem Gerät nicht mehr vertrauen kann. Da ist wie so eine kleine Person auf meinem Gerät, was sich jede von meinen Chat-Nachrichten anguckt und jedes Bild und jeweils kurz sich so an den Bart fasst und überlegt, hm.
Ist das eigentlich gut oder nicht?
Und wenn ich Pech habe auslege, aus äh richtigen oder aus falschen Gründen, wird mein Gerät sich gegen mich entscheiden und illoyal werden,
und statt die Nachricht, die ich eigentlich Khalesi schicken wollte, tatsächlich an Kalesi zu schicken, einfach jemand anderes schicken. Das heißt, ich kann mein Gerät hat wie eine Pads-Funktion eingebaut
von der ich nicht sicher sein kann, dass sie korrekt funktioniert und dass sie auf jeden Fall technisch in der Lage ist, Dinge, die wirklich nur für Khalisi gedacht waren, an irgendjemand anderes zu schicken.
Und das ist ein massives Problem, weil ich nicht bei jeder Nachricht weiß, ich kann mir nicht mehr sicher sein, es ist relativ wahrscheinlich, aber ich weiß nicht genau.
Wie gut dieser diese kleine Person, die da sitzt und sich am Bart krault, ähm wie gut die diese Sachen entscheiden kann. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie gut die in der Lage ist, aber wie wohlgesonnen die mir ist, ob ich mich gut verstehe oder nicht, ob die mir vielleicht auch, also,
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Muss man einfach sagen und die kann auch einfach Fehler machen und das, wir können uns nicht mehr drauf verlassen, dass das tatsächlich passiert und das ist das ist das Problem.
Das heißt, ihr habt so ein ganz grundsätzliches Misstrauen gegenüber EU-Behörden? Höre ich das richtig raus?
Also ich glaube, es also ja, ein grundsätzliches ähm Misstrauen gegenüber ähm EU-Behörden ist, glaube ich, durchaus angemessen, also wenn man als Beispiel nimmt, dass Europol ja
ungern illegal erhobene Daten löschen möchte, zum Beispiel ähm kann man da durchaus von einem Misstrauen.
Ausgehen, aber ich glaube, was uns an dieser Stelle viel wichtiger ist der Punkt ist, dass wir vertrauenswürdige Kommunikation sicherstellen, also dass mein Gerät, ich vergleiche das immer wie ein mit einem Tagebuch, also
ein Smartphone ist eigentlich das persönlichste, was wir
haben. Wir tippen da alle unsere eigenen Gedanken. Wir tippen da alle Gedanken, die wir mit der Familie oder Freundinnen und Partnerinnen teilen möchten rein
und genauso wie beim Tagebuch wollen wir auch wirklich, wirklich, wirklich die Macht dadrüber haben.
Wer da reingucken darf und wer nicht. Und das ist glaube ich der Punkt
der hier so massiv wichtig ist, dass mein Gerät, also dass ich der Herr oder die Herrin meines Gerätes bin und durch Kleinzeit-Scanning würde dieser Part.
Mir genommen werden und das ist für mich das größte und das Schlimmste Störgefühl, was man eigentlich haben kann, also
Sicherheitsforscherinnen haben das als diese ganze Apple-Debatte zu klein seit aufkam als bezeichnet und das ist halt sehr treffend, also das führt,
A auch zu anderen Sicherheitsimplikationen, aber primär halt dazu, dass ich meinem Gerät nicht mehr vertrauen kann.
Können vielleicht auch sagen, wir haben ja nicht mal also ich persönlich halte das nicht mal eine.
Eine eine Fehler aus bösem Willen für das Wahrscheinlichste, sondern einfach aus Inkompetenz Slash.
Fehlender Leistung von diesen Erkennungssystemen, weil wenn wir uns überlegen, wir haben, ich glaube, eine halbe Milliarde Chatnachrichten pro Tag in der EU, da ist jedes System, was sich auch nur bei jeder tausendsten Nachricht irrt.
Entstehen immer noch gigantische Mengen an Chatnachrichten, die völlig
unberechtigterweise an die Polizei weitergeleitet wurden und bei jeder Chatnachricht von mir weiß ich nicht genau, okay ja fuck, wenn ich im Jahr 1.000 Nachrichten verschicke und dieses Ding, jede zehntausend, jede tausendste Sache falscherweise erkennt, dann landen ja zehn Nachrichten pro Jahr
der Polizei von mir, welche denn jetzt? Ist es jetzt die nächste? Keine Ahnung. Und dieses dieses Urvertrauen in meinen verschlüsselten Kanal, das ist dann halt weg.
Ich frage mich gerade, ist euch in der Diskussion, wenn ihr wenn ihr das sozusagen vortragt, auch schon das Argument begegnet
Also ich habe das in anderen Situationen manchmal gehört, deswegen frage ich euch das jetzt, dass Leute dann sagen, ja, na gut, das ist schon was anderes, aber die Leute geben ja in den sozialen Netzwerken eh so viel von sich preis. Da macht das ja auch keinen Unterschied mehr.
Also diese Frage ist uns tatsächlich noch nicht so begegnet, deswegen finde ich das sehr interessant ähm mein Argument wäre da einfach.
Ein man könnte es auch ein bisschen naiv nennen, aber
Menschen sind sich ja in sozialen Netzwerken darüber bewusst, dass das öffentlich einsehbar ist.
Wenn ich jetzt aber meinen meinen Partner, meiner Partnerin zum Beispiel Nacktbild schicken möchte, dann habe ich ja überhaupt gar kein Interesse daran, dass es jemals.
Von irgendjemand anderem außer meinem Partner oder meiner Partnerin gesehen werden wird. So und ich glaube, das ist der entscheidende Unterschied und ich glaube, das ist auch etwas, was uns allen klar ist, dass es einfach Dinge gibt,
die wir auch so nie auf öffentlichen Social Media Kanälen teilen wollen würden.
Gibt es denn eigentlich bei diesem Ding ähm.
Das ist ja bei anderen Überwachungsgesetzgebungen manchmal passiert, dass Leute gesagt haben, also da da also das wollen wir vor allen Dingen machen, um äh Missbrauchsabbildungen zu verhindern und dann kommt äh irgendwie.
Drei Tage, drei Monate, sechs Jahre später immer sagt, ja aber wir könnten's auch für Steuerfahndung benutzen oder bei Drogendelikten oder bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen. Ist das hier auch schon sozusagen? Gibt's da auch schon Leute, die diese Idee haben?
Ja und das ist tatsächlich total interessant. Also wir sind jetzt noch nicht in so das Rechtliche so eingestiegen. Mhm. Aber das ist nicht nur die Ablösung für die bisherig bestehende Verordnung
sondern das ist auch eine Spezifizierung für den Digital Services Act. Also der Digital Service ist Act, der ist.
Aus ich glaube aus aus der Datenschutz Bubble gesehen relativ glimpflich verlaufen und relativ.
Gut für uns verlaufen, aber alles, was sie sozusagen im Digital Service Act nicht durchbekommen haben, finden wir jetzt in dieser Verordnung wieder und diese Verordnung ist halt sehr generell und.
Schwammig formuliert und jetzt, ich sage mal, Kindesmissbrauchsstellung äh Darstellung
durch äh Terror zum Beispiel auszutauschen, ist nicht so wahnsinnig weit hergeholt. Also man muss sich immer der Sache bewusst sein, dass wenn man durch eine solche Verordnung ein derartiges Überwachungswerkzeug
schafft, schafft es auch immer die Möglichkeit, das auf andere Bereiche auszuweiten, weil es ist da und ob ich jetzt nach äh
Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellung in Form von Bildherrschesuche oder nach äh Terrordarstellung, sage ich mal so, in Anführungsstrichen.
Der Unterschied ist Technologie bezogen gar nicht so riesig. Also das heißt, es gibt noch konkret keine.
Von äh keine Ansätze, von denen ihr gehört haben, aber ihr geht davon aus, das könnte dann sehr leicht zugleich passieren. Ja, man muss auch immer sagen.
Wenn wir solche Werkzeuge bauen, dann baut Mieter das Jahr.
Und Meter gibt es nicht nur in Europa. Das heißt, es ist ja nicht nur so, dass dieses Werkzeug durch neue Gesetzgebungen auf EU-Ebene missbraucht werden kann.
Sondern dass wenn wir in repressiven Staaten landen mit diesen entsprechend Firmen, die sagen hm also für die EU da habt ihr doch diese coole Kleinzeit-Scanning Technologie gebaut. Wir haben hier so ein paar politische Gruppen, die uns ein bisschen nerven. Wir würden das jetzt gerne nutzen
um deren Kommunikation mal ein bisschen zu überwachen und zu stören. So, der Sache sollte man sich halt auch bewusst sein, die man da im Hinterkopf behalten sollte.
Ist es, ist es eigentlich sozusagen im Endeffekt dann so ein bisschen eine Diskussion, dass die Befürworter sagen, ja gut äh man kann das richtig bauen und dann funktioniert das auch und
Die Kritikerinnen, die sagen so, nee, die alleine die Idee macht das System quasi kaputt.
Also ähm ich habe noch überhaupt keine,
Vorstellung gesehen von irgendjemand, wie man das technisch korrekt bauen könnte, tatsächlich. Also ich niemand in diesem Gesetz steht es nicht drin und niemand konnte überzeugend für mich persönlich überzeugend darstellen, wie man das
alles technisch umsetzen könnte, ohne dass es eine völlige Katastrophe wird. Du siehst
nachdenklich aus? Na ja, also ich glaube, der wichtige Punkt ist, also was heißt technisch korrekt bauen? Also das hat.
Diese Medaille hat für mich zwei Seiten, nämlich einmal die Seite können wir's privats fairefreundlich bauen, so wie wir DatenschützerInnen uns das vorstellen.
Und die andere Seite der Medaille ist aber, können wir es so bauen, dass es nicht für andere Zwecke missbraucht werden kann?
Das sind für mich zwei Seiten der Medaille, die äh die Befürworterinnen werden jetzt sagen, na ja, wir haben das in der Verordnung ja so pro Privatsphäre geregelt.
Dass das ja gar nicht zu missbrauchen ist, aber was sie was sie nicht,
betrachtet haben, ist halt das, was ich eben grade gesagt hat, wenn man ein solches Werkzeug schafft, kann es immer für andere Dinge verwendet werden.
Und es ist einfach eine super, ne, wie du gesagt hast, eine super Argumentationshilfe für irgendwelche repressiven Staaten, auch auf der politischen, auf dem politischen Parkett zu sagen, hey, mach das doch auch. Ich will das jetzt auch haben und
Was ich noch äh ergänzen wollte ist, wenn man sich
ähm die äh netzpolitische Geschichte der letzten sechs, sieben Jahre der EU anguckt. Ich habe das mal ein bisschen zusammengefasst für heute. Es ist die ganze Zeit, seit 2015 fordert da irgendjemand und hat irgendeine Sicherheitsbehörde, die tolle Idee, dass die Verschlüsselung schon auch ein Problem ist und dass es doch eigentlich direkt
Zugriff für Sicherheitsbehörden auf eigentlich verschlüsselte Inhalte geben müsste. Was wiederum nur eine der fünf von mir äh vorhin vorgestellten Lösungs,
Ansätze braucht, ne, Staatstrojaner, Kleinzeitscanning, ähm diese Sachen und die ganze Zeit
Da gibt's einen tollen Netzpolitikartikel dazu, den machen wir vielleicht auch in die Show, dass die ganze Zeit seitdem sagt irgendwie der britische Premierminister. Wir wollen das verbieten, wenn wir nicht reingucken können, sagt die EU, ach ja, wir hätten hier gerne eigentlich, wir wollen auch Zugang zu Staats- und Sicherheitsbehörden ähm.
Sagen die die Five Eyes, also USA, Kanada, Australien, England.
Australien sagen, äh hier, das ist ja totales Problem, dass wir da nicht mehr reingucken können, gibt's dieses Golden Dark-Narrativ von AW als Geheimdienst. Sie können gar nicht mehr arbeiten. Wenn ihr jetzt hier alles verschlüsselt habt
und
Es gab sogar zwanzig 20, also nicht lange her unter deutschem EU-Ratsvorsitz gab es diese Entschließung, da hat ähm Khalesi gerade schon von erzählt, von Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und sicher trotz Verschlüsselung, nennen sie das und auch da formulieren sie, na ja, eigentlich muss es doch,
Trotz Verschlüsselung irgendeine Möglichkeit geben, bitte dass wir ähm auf die Inhalte zugreifen können, selbst wenn die Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt waren,
und wenn man das jetzt so zieht, also wenn man diese ganzen Punkte verbindet Perfektion also sie haben ein ein neue juristische Perfektion erreicht in dieser in diesem Gesetzesvorschlag ähm
Genau und das ist jetzt vielleicht eine Unterstellung, weil das hat natürlich niemand damit begründet,
aber einfach jetzt, wenn man sich nur diese Datenpunkte anguckt, dass da seit äh fünf, sechs Jahren rumort das in diesem Kessel und jedes Jahr kommt irgendjemand auf die Idee zu fordern, ey, eigentlich müssen wir aber was machen. Dieses Gesetz ist jetzt nicht mal per se dazu geeignet
richtig an die Inhalte in großer Menge ranzukommen, aber es ist trotzdem ein brachialer Angriff auf dieses Konzept von.
Wirklich vertrauenswürdiger Kommunikation, wo ich wirklich sehr vertrauen kann, dass die Inhalte nur bei der Person ankommen, an die ich sie geschickt habe und damit für sich absolut in dieser Reihe zu sehen.
Da muss man doch mal fragen, also ne, wenn wenn die Expertinnen seit Jahren daran arbeiten, warum zur Hölle ist euch denn jetzt diese vertrauliche Kommunikation so wichtig?
Ich glaube, wir sollten da ähm also zu zu zwei Seiten zurückgehen. Erstmal würde ich gerne zu diesem Thema repressive starten.
Zurückgehen, also in Deutschland könnte man so sagen, ja äh wenn ich hier irgendwie Viktor eine Demoaufruf gegen die Chatkontrolle schicke, dann auch wenn die Bundesregierung das doof findet, ist das nicht so das Problem, weil.
Eine freie Meinungsäußerung ist für uns gesichert.
Aber wenn ich in ein anderes Land gehe, dann kann das schon sein, dass das zur politischen Verfolgung führen kann. So, das heißt, erst mal, damit irgendwie,
ich demonstrieren kann oder ich Informationen zu irgendwelchen Sachen gegen die man zum Beispiel politisch sein kann, austauschen kann, ist das total wichtig. Und dann gibt es natürlich Berufsgruppen, die grundsätzlich Interesse an vertrauenswürdiger Kommunikation haben. Also
Anwältinnen, Ärztinnen, aber auch Journalistinnen und.
Haben vorhin ja schon mal den Namen Edward Snowden gehört, Whistleblowerin, die halt wirklich gefährdet sein können, wenn irgendwie rauskommt, dass sie Dinge.
Weitergegeben haben oder nach außen kommuniziert haben. Also es ist quasi ein gesellschaftlich.
Wichtiges Ding, dass wir einen Weg haben, wirklich unter uns zu bleiben. Genau, also das ist genau, also es ich sage mal, es gibt ja so dieses ähm.
Und dieses diesen Begriff von dem
Chilling-Effekt, das ist im Rahmen dieser Kampagne auch sehr schön erklärt. Das Video können wir gerne auch nochmal verlinken. Das heißt, wenn ich weiß, dass ich prinzipiell
beobachtet werde, verhalte ich mich automatisch konformer zu, zum Beispiel dem Regime, in dem ich mich bewege. So das hat halt sehr krasse Auswirkungen auf meine,
Meinungsäußerungen und auch die Art, wie ich mich zum Beispiel politisch organisieren würde, wenn ich mit etwas, was in meinem Land passiert ist,
politisch nicht so einverstanden bin.
Und es ist realistisch gesehen auch deine einzige Art, deine einzige Chance dich zu Protest zu verabreden in einem repressiven Überwachungsstaat. Mhm.
Mir ist jetzt gerade noch eine Detailfrage äh.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr euch damit auch beschäftigt habt, weil ich ich habe das so ausm Auge ähm beim beim Lesen, dass die das was damit auch stattfinden kann, ist, weil die Regeln dafür, was
unter sozusagen unter Abbildung von Kindesmissbrauch fällt irgendwie relativ ähm oder die sind in der Art und Weise gefasst. Also ich will so fummeln, die sind in einer Art und Weise gefasst, dass
junge Menschen die sich gegenseitig Nachrichten sexueller Natur schicken äh da auch drunter fallen könnten.
Ist das eine sozusagen muss man dann hier von der Kriminalisierung von Jugendlichen sprechen oder ist das ein anderes Thema? Also das ist
Ich kann nicht sagen, wie's in anderen EU-Staaten ist. Ich kann nur für Deutschland sprechen. In Deutschland ist es tatsächlich so, dass dass der Austausch von.
Kinderpornografischen Material zwischen Minderjährigen ein Straftatbestand ist.
So, das heißt, wenn ich 16 bin und meinem 16-jährigen Partnerin ein Nacktfoto von mir schicke, dann ist das eine Straftat.
Mhm. Und das dann sozusagen aber das ist im Rahmen dieser Verordnung, wie wir sprechen, aber eher sozusagen so eine Nebenbaustelle, dass da dass dann sozusagen das auch noch zusätzliche Effekte hätte. Man äh.
Ist das oder ist es sozusagen in eine Brüder Brüdere Gesellschaft? Nein, also jein. Ich glaube, es spricht eigentlich ein Problem an, was man an anderer Stelle lösen könnten und nicht durch diese Verordnung. Ähm denn.
Also das erste Problem ist natürlich, dass die Ermittlungsbehörden jetzt schon von der schieren Menge von Bildmaterialien überlastet sind und wenn dann jetzt sozusagen noch die.
Die Fotos, die sich Minderjährige zuschicken, da muss man jetzt auch noch mal wieder einhaken und sagen, okay, woher weiß ich denn, dass das zwei minderjährige Kommunikationsteilnehmerinnen sind? Das heißt, ich
wäre eigentlich schon an der Stelle angekommen, wo ich sagen müsste, ich muss.
Age verification, also die Sicherstellung des Alters und damit halt auch der Identität der Kommunikationspartner einführen. So, aber das ist ein anderer Schauplatz. Mhm. Ähm.
Und das würde halt heißen, dass ganz, ganz viel Bildmaterial einfach auftauchen könnte.
Das eigentlich total unproblematisch in Anführungsstrichen ist, aber ähm in Deutschland halt juristisch gesehen eine Straftat und.
Dieser Straftat müssen die Ermittlungsbehörden natürlich nachgehen, haben aber weniger Zeit,
das zu tun, was ich vorhin meinte, nämlich sich in solche Darknet-Foren, zum Beispiel.
Einzuschleusen. Und was man halt stattdessen machen könnte, wäre natürlich eine massive Aufklärungskampagne für Jugendliche, um denen zu erklären.
Was eigentlich das Problem mit Nacktbilder versenden ist. Ich will jetzt nicht Jugendliche davon abhalten Nacktbilder zu versenden.
Bei Gott nicht, aber ich glaube, dass halt eine Aufklärungskampagne an dieser Stelle halt wesentlich angebrachter wäre.
Genau und ich glaube, es ist vielleicht an diesem Punkt auch nochmal schlau, das nochmal aufzuschlüsseln, wie man das denn konkret umsetzen könnte, weil das haben wir, glaube ich, angerissen schon. Es gibt,
prinzipiell zwei Möglichkeiten. Du kannst erstmal nach Bekanntem dir bereits bekanntem Material suchen oder du kannst sagen, ich habe hier eine zauberhafte KI und die wird pro,
Foto Protext für sich selber entscheiden, ob es sich hierbei eben um illegitimes Material handelt oder nicht. Beides hat massive Probleme. Wenn ich nach bekanntem Material suche, dann muss ich,
Wie gesagt, die die Fingerabdrücke, die Hashes von allen Materialien, nach denen ich suche.
Muss sich runtergeladen haben auf das Gerät. Das Gerät muss die irgendwie kennen, um danach suchen zu können. Ich hatte das mal überschlagen. Ich hoffe, ich habe da keine,
Multiplikationsfehler gemacht, aber das würde vermutlich zu auf jedem Handy zu zehn Gigabyte an Hashes führen, die da einfach rumliegen müssen, damit das Handy, weil das das auf dem Handy müsst ihr an Hash von jedem erdenklichen,
Kindesmissbrauchs, Abbildungsdings sein und nur wenn das der Fall ist, kann das Handy das dann immer scannen, du willst was sagen?
Oder es würde dazu führen, dass ich immer einen Teil Hash von dem Bild an den Server schicken muss und mir dann alle,
sozusagen angucken muss, die zu diesem Teil Hash passen und die mir runterladen würde und dann
den ganzen Hashtag gegen die heruntergeladenen Hasheses checken würde und das würde natürlich weniger Speicherplatz kosten, aber natürlich wesentlich länger dauern als das direkt aufm Gerät abzugleichen
Das ist dann auch wieder eine Frage, wie plausibel ist es, dass sie da ein super crazy fancy äh Kryptosystem bauen werden? Ich glaube da nicht dran.
Das ist die eine, die eine Version ist, dass man sagt äh wir laden die ganzen runter oder wir prüfen gegen Kantus-Material.
Die zweite Version ist und danach sieht es aus nach allem, was wir gehört haben.
Ist, dass man das überhaupt nicht einschränkt und dass man mehr sagt, okay, wir haben eine super coole KI auf dem Gerät, die sich jedes Foto anguckt und sich jede Chatnachricht anguckt.
Jeweils für sich entscheiden, finde ich das relativ wahrscheinlich, dass es sich dabei um den Kindesmissbrauchserbildung oder um so einen Anbahnungsversuch handelt und da kommen wir jetzt wieder zurück
zu den Nacktfotos, die sich Jugendliche geschickt haben jetzt äh bestimmte Ähnlichkeiten, also die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
Es wird immer eine Wahrscheinlichkeit geben, dass das Zeugs fälschlicherweise erkannt wird, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es fälschlicherweise erkannt wird, wird natürlich größer, je mehr es sich da um,
sexuelle Nachrichten zwischen Erwachsenen handelt oder ein Kind von deinem Foto am Strand, was du deiner Oma geschickt hast
oder um Nacktfotos, die sich Jugendliche gegenseitig geschickt haben, weil das natürlich, ne, nackte Haut, irgendwie sexuelle Begriffe, das ist dann irgendwie näher dran, deshalb ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass das dann auch unter anderem die Sachen sind.
Die da landen werden und der das realistische Szenario, von dem ich absolut ausgeh ist, dass du davon ausgehst.
Wenn du ein Kind ein Foto von deinem Strandurlaub nacktes Kind äh dass es eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt, dass das Ding bei einer entweder bei einer Kontrollstelle oder bei der Polizei landet.
Und davon gibt's extrem viele Fotos und selbst wenn du jedes tausendste davon weitergeleitet wird, sind das immer noch krank viele Fotos,
Kindern, die wir auf einmal irgendwo sammeln. Ich glaube, jetzt macht's so langsam bei mir zu denken, okay, das ist also eine Welt, in der wir dann leben, wo du wo du quasi bei jeder, bei jeder Messenger-Nachricht, die du schreibst, überlegen musst,
oder quasi das Gefühl hast so, dass diese diese Nachricht, dieses Bild, was ich hiermit schicke, vielleicht ist das der Punkt, wo ich.
Besuch von der Polizei bekommen. Genau und wir haben ja noch nicht über die Anbahnungsversuche gesprochen. Anbahnungsversuche erfolgen ja nicht durch Memes oder Bilder oder so etwas, sondern die erfolgen ja prinzipiell
eher in Form von.
Textnachrichten, das heißt, ich muss mir diesen Gedanken nicht immer nur machen, wenn ich ein Bild verschicke, sondern ich muss mir diesen Gedanken auch machen, wenn ich zum Beispiel
meiner kleinen Nichte, aber egal eigentlich auch wem, eine Textnachricht schicke,
also da habe ich jetzt gar nicht mehr drüber nachgedacht und sagen, weil das mit dem Bild sozusagen immer das vorher Thema war, aber da frage ich mich ja, wie macht man das denn? Also man äh Schlagwortssuche oder ist dann auch eine KI, die Textanalyse macht und dann sind wir ja wirklich dabei, das irgendwie.
Der komplette Chatverlauf, also wird? Ganz genau, so sieht's nämlich aus.
Zuerst gesagt, hätte ich gleich an der Seite entzündet. Genau, das ist nämlich das Problem dieser Anbahnungsversuche, dieses Grooming.
Texterkennung ist relativ einfach, sage ich mal, in Anführungsstrichen. Ähm dann aber zu erkennen, ähm wie die sprachlichen Muster sind,
und ähm ob das jetzt ein Anbahnungsversuch ist oder nicht, da kommt jetzt wieder dieses ganze Thema, was ich eben schon angerissen habe ins Spiel.
Klar kann man KIs bauen, die versuchen zu erkennen anhand der Art, wie Menschen schreiben, wie das Alter von den beiden Personen, die an der Konversation beteiligt sind, schätzen kann
aber das ist ziemlich
ungenau, weil man auch weiß, dass ähm Personen, die solche Anbahnungsversuche starten, sich eher an den Sprachgebrauch von
jüngere Nutzerinnen anpassen. Das heißt, eigentlich muss ich, um wirklich.
In Anführungsstrichen sinnvoll, Grooming-Versuche zu erkennen, nicht nur eine KI über jeden Text jagen, der rausgeht, sondern auch noch wissen, wer das am anderen Ende ist und wie alt der ist, um es wirklich sicher sagen zu können.
Das heißt, es kann halt dazu kommen, dass wir uns dann halt
wirklich ausweisen müssen, um solche Dienste nutzen zu können. Ja, aber ist doch super. Dann haben wir doch gleich noch die Klarnamenpflicht erledigt oder? Genau. Nicht eh im Internet haben. Genau, also wirklich dieser dieser
Entwurf und diese Verordnung ist eine bunte Tüte an Dingen, die wir in den letzten fünf Jahren
größtenteils verhindern konnten, die jetzt nochmal anklopft und sagt so hey wir versuchen's nochmal. Also.
Die ganzen Stehauffiguren. So also ich bin überzeugt, ja? Ich bin überzeugt äh Stempel drauf sozusagen keine gute Idee.
Was ich bei EU-Gesetzgebung aber immer spannend finde und das würde ich, das würde ich gerne heute machen,
ist, ähm weil ich das auch als jemand, der sozusagen, wenn man das als als ähm Publikum verfolgt, habe ich, denke ich immer so, der Aufschrei ist immer total groß.
Denkst du so, oh mein Gott
Das ist die letzte Möglichkeit das zu verhindern. Dann ist ein langer Artikel und dann äh ja und jetzt muss noch als nächstes ist der Kommission da irgendwie Trilog, keine Ahnung was auch immer, dann liest du das nach und denkst du ah so, okay das war also ein Schritt im Gesetzgebungsfall, aha mhm okay der nächste kommt auch noch mal so, also ich will jetzt nicht runterreden, das ist nicht dramatisch ist, ne, weil inhaltlich ist es das natürlich
Aber ich grade bei EU-Gesetzgebung ist es immer, finde ich, sehr schwer, aufm Schirm zu haben, an welcher Stelle stehen wir gerade und das würde ich gerne jetzt
gegen Ende sozusagen, wir nähern uns, glaube ich, langsam gerne noch wissen wollen. Und Punkt mit Punkt eins anfangen, ihr habt gesagt, das ist eine Verordnung, um die es geht,
Was ist eine Verordnung? Genau, also auf EU-Ebene.
Begegnen uns meistens zwei Arten. Das sind einmal die Verordnungen und einmal die Richtlinien. Die Richtlinien sind solche ähm Gesetzgebungen, die dann auch noch von Staaten auf nationaler Ebene
umgesetzt und durchgesetzt werden müssen, wären Verordnungen sozusagen direkt von oben erlassen werden und dann auch direkt also
nicht noch mal in nationale Gesetzgebung umgesetzt werden müssen, sondern so wie das in dem Entwurf steht, gilt es dann auch. Da gibt es dann auch keine zwei Meinungen drüber
So, das ist eine Verordnung und ich kann das total gut verstehen, dass das für viele auf EU-Ebene
immer sehr intransparent und schwierig zu verstehen ist. Man muss auch dazu sagen diese EU-Ebenen mal langsam. Also wir sprechen da häufig nicht von Monaten, die das dauern kann, bis das entschieden ist, sondern von Jahren. Also man muss da immer einen sehr langen Atem haben und das liegt da dran
das ein bisschen aufwendiger ist oder komplizierter als bei uns ähm.
Vielleicht im Bundestag der Fall. Also wir haben sozusagen drei ähm unterschiedliche
Ich sage mal ja Gremien ähm also wir haben einmal die Kommission. Wir haben jetzt am Anfang gesagt, okay dieser Gesetzesentwurf der kommt von der Kommission. Die Kommission macht einen Vorschlag für einen Gesetzesentwurf.
Und dann gibt es noch den warte warte stopp. Wenn wir jetzt schon kleine einfache in die EU rechnen, äh die EU-Gesetzgebung machen. Was ist die Kommission?
Das ist ein bisschen wie die Regierung.
Genau. Also das sind die Leute, die die sind auch glaube ich mehr oder weniger gewählt und die bringen die Gesetzesvorschläge in diese ganze Mühle.
Mhm. Riesige Gebäude in Brüssel und jetzt, wenn wir in diesem Gesetzgebungsprozess sind, die machen einen Vorschlag und die haben auch,
wieso die die Spitze, das ist die Ursula von der Leyen aktuell und dann haben die die einzelnen äh ähm Referate, könnte man sagen, also gibt es ähm das Kommissariat und da gibt es dann ähm
äh zum Beispiel eine Innenkommissarin und das ist eben die Jene Ilva Johansen, von dem wir gerade geredet haben und
die unter ihrer Leitung, die hat sicherlich ein sehr großes Team, ist da ein entsprechender Gesetzesentwurf entstanden? Also, äh ich will nochmal zusammenfassen.
Es gibt also die EU-Kommission quasi so eine Art Regierung oder das analoge und seiner sozusagen. Die Exekutive, die haben jetzt eine Verordnung vorgeschlagen. Verordnung heißt in dem Moment, wenn die entschieden wird,
gilt die auch so in allen EU-Ländern, Punkt. Genau. So, aber sie ist in Anführungszeichen nur
ein Vorschlag. Der Vorschlag wird jetzt gerade heiß diskutiert, was passiert im Gesetz und was zu sagen, was ist der nächste Schritt, was sind die Aussichten im Gesetzgebungsprozess? An als nächstes geht es an die anderen beiden Organe, nämlich einmal den
EU-Ministerinnenrat und einmal an das Parlament.
So. So, jetzt herzusagen, ne? Als jemand, der nicht so viel Ahnung hat von der EU. Parlament, okay, kennen wir sozusagen, da wird gewählt, da gehen wir selber schon mal, das sind das ist das ist ein Parlament. Aber Ministerin Rat, ihr habt doch gerade gesagt, die EU-Kommission ist.
So eine Art Regierung mit Ministern. Was ist der Ministerrat.
Genau also die die Kommission ist mit Kommissar Kommissarin und der Ministerinnenrat, da gibt es dann auch unterschiedliche Fachministerinnenräte, also zum Beispiel was hier interessant ist, den für Inneres.
Da wäre dann zum Beispiel für Deutschland, nennt sie Phaser drin. Also das heißt, der Ministerinnenrat ist nicht sozusagen ein Rat aus EU-Ministern, sondern da sitzen die Fachminister aus den jeweiligen Ländern in einem Rat zusammen. Genau.
Ja
Sprechen jetzt dadrüber. Genau, die sprechen intern miteinander dadrüber. Also der Ministerinnenrat diskutiert es für sich und das EU-Parlament diskutiert es für sich. Mhm. So. Macht das EU-Parlament dann auch eine Abstimmung?
Wird dadrüber gewählt im Parlament? Irgendwann wird dadrüber gewählt im Parlament, genau. Und äh
Nein, noch nicht. Ah. Also das ist das Wichtige. Also es wird es gibt sowohl im Ministerinnenrat als auch im Parlament eine Abstimmung dadrüber und wenn das irgendwo
scheitert, dann ist es erstmal sozusagen vorbei und wenn es irgendwo stecken bleibt, weil das die Mühlen der Verwaltung mal langsam, dann dauert das halt so lange, wie es halt eben dauert, bis das Thema durchdiskutiert ist.
Mhm. Das heißt, es reicht, wenn es in einen von diesen drei Institutionen schief, also wenn alle drei Institutionen sagt, finden wir geil, dann ist es beschlossene Sache. Genau und eine ist ja jetzt schon raus, weil die Kommission hat ja schon gesagt.
Finden wir aber wie ist denn das jetzt wenn jetzt sozusagen keine Ahnung das Parlament sagt so also im Prinzip ja aber folgende Änderung geht in die ganze Runde von vorne los?
Nee, also das die können dann sozusagen ein bisschen Pingpong damit spielen. Also jeder kann seine Änderungsanträge einbringen,
Ähm und ganz, ganz zum Schluss, das kennen wir alle. Also für mich ist immer so in meinem Kopf ganz fest verankert, wenn wir im Trilog sind, dann haben wir eigentlich fast verloren.
So, also die versuchen sich dann sozusagen auf eine Form zu einigen, mit der sie alle leben können.
Und wenn sie das nicht kommen, dann kommt ganz zum Schluss halt dieser Trilog, wo sie's dann noch mal final versuchen zusammenzubringen.
Kann man sich das vorstellen? Widersetzen sie sich gleichzeitig an einem Tisch und reden miteinander? Genau.
Okay. So ähm jetzt habt ihr ja schon am Anfang gesagt irgendwie anzünden ist eine Option. An welcher Stelle kann das denn am besten scheitern, wenn ich die Frage mal so stellen darf?
Das ist tatsächlich eine Frage, die wir nicht so einfach beantworten. Also es kann an sehr vielen Stellen scheitern und wir.
Konnten uns auch also es gibt glaube ich keine bessere oder schlechtere Stelle. Mhm. Grundsätzlich können wir erstmal.
Versuchen, auf die jeweilige Ministerin, in diesem Fall Nancy Phaser Druck auszuüben und zu sagen, hey, das ist eine ziemlich doofe Idee.
Bitte tu was dagegen.
Also und sie vor allen Dingen an den Koalitionsvertrag zu erinnern, in dem ein Recht auf zu Ende Verschlüsselung ähm verankert ist.
Das ist sozusagen der erste Angriffspunkt und der zweite Angriffspunkt ist seine Parlamentarierin zu kontaktieren.
Und zu sagen okay.
Das ist eine ganz blöde Idee, die anzurufen oder denen zu schreiben und denen zu erklären, warum das ein Problem ist mit dieser Chatkontrolle.
Jetzt ist es doch aber so, wenn ich die Medien richtig verfolgt habe, so toll ist, wie ich von den Medien sprechen, bin ich die Medien verfolgt habe
sieht das doch gar nicht so schlecht aus vor allen Dingen Deutschen auch eine Frau Feser doch schon gesagt haben so ja so eine gute Idee ist die lass mal lass mal nicht machen ist das nicht schon ist der Drops nicht schon gelutscht,
ne, also ganz einfach ist es leider nicht. Natürlich nicht. Wenn äh wenn eine Ministerin ähm
Wenn eine Ministerin twittert und sagt, also erst mal hat sie ja gesagt, sie findet das total unterstützendwert. Das muss man ja erstmal historisch oder chronologisch betrachten.
Und das ist so ein bisschen wie bei dieser ganzen Heckback-Geschichte, dann ist so ein bisschen Zeit vergangen. Wir haben schon Wetten-Apfel geschlossen, wie lange es wohl dauern wird, bis sie wieder zurückrudern wird. Und dann hat sie gedacht, ah, nee, doch nicht. Vielleicht ist das doch nicht so die gute Idee. Mhm. Aber
grundsätzlich ist das noch nicht 100 Prozent offiziell. Ich würde sagen, es wackelt. Ähm denn Nancy Phaser.
Sieht halt auch und das ist oder sagt halt auch, es gibt dieses Problem und es ist ein Riesenproblem und wir müssen da was gegen tun. So. Mhm. Und.
Genau und da da könnte man jetzt sagen, sie hat jetzt die einmalige Chance, dass tatsächlich zu zeigen, dass sie da technisch verstanden hat, was in dem Gesetzesentwurf drinsteht und sieht,
das was passieren muss nicht eine äh ein Scanning von Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation ist, sondern ganz andere Sachen sind.
Und hat die Chance zu zeigen, dass sie da nicht irgendwelche Symbolpolitik hinterherläuft, weil wie gesagt,
Ist sicherlich gut gemeint, aber das, was da gefordert wird, mit dem Scan von Verschlüsselerkommunikation, das wird nichts bringen und das ist total gefährlich und deshalb wünschen wir natürlich, dass Sie die Weitsicht und politische Stärke haben wird,
entsprechend den Koalitionsvertrag umzusetzen und äh unseren äh deutschen und europäischen Werten gerecht zu werden und zu sagen, nee, das machen wir so nicht.
Also um das mal grad zu sagen, ne? Ihr arbeitet nicht daran, äh da irgendwie eine Umsetzung zu finden, die da machbar ist, sondern das Ding so einfach weg. Genau, also da kann man vielleicht noch mal drauf zurückkommen, also es ist so ein bisschen rechtlich ähm und ein bisschen trocken. Also diese.
Diese Gesetzes ähm Entwurf ist unter Artikel 140 der äh EU ähm angeordnet und das ist ähm der Bereich, der sich auf Märkte bezieht.
So und was das heißt, das ist ein Gesetz, das nur eine Umsetzung von Maßnahmen beschreibt, die in
Märkten, also von Unternehmen umgesetzt werden können. Das heißt, jegliche Kompromissvorschläge, die wir uns überlegen würden, wie mehr
Prävention, mehr Gelder für Ermittlungsbehörden und so weiter und so fort, die könnten wir da gar nicht einbringen, weil das keine Sachen sind, die im Markt
geregelt werden können.
Okay, ich meinte, ich meinte tatsächlich äh gar nicht so sehr die ähm die Frage, was machen wir gegen äh Abbildung von Kindesmissbrauch, sondern ich rede jetzt von dieser von diesem technischen Dingen. Okay. Also von diesem davon, dass äh,
dass irgendwie Anbieter von Kommunikationsinfrastrukturen sicherstellen sollen, dass das passiert. Das soll als Konzept,
doch einfach weg. Gefährlich und muss weg. Aber deswegen und die anschließende politische Diskussion ist sozusagen, dass man dann sagt so, liebe Leute.
Das Thema ist wichtig, aber das muss an anderer Stelle abfinden, nämlich nicht bei Artikel hundert140, wo so eine Markt geht, sondern genau und das ist halt wichtig zu verstehen. Alle Leute, die sagen, ja, aber ihr müsst doch Kompromisse anbieten und so weiter und so fort.
Wir bieten diese Kompromisse gerne an. Es muss aber allen Menschen klar sein, dass wir sie nicht.
Mit diesem Gesetz, in dieser Art unter dieser Aufhängung lösen können, sondern dass wir sagen müssen, so geht mal zurück zu euren Whiteboards und denkt euch was Neues aus und denkt noch mal drüber nach.
Wo man das wirklich sinnvoll aufhängen kann und vor allem macht es besser, weil also niemand wird bezweifeln, dass es ein riesiges Problem ist, also haben wir vielleicht auch noch nicht in ausführlichen Volumen genug erzählt, ne, also Kindesmissbrauch ist eine schreckliche Sache. Das Versenden von Künstler ist aus
Mitbrauch Abbildung muss auf jeden Fall verhindert werden, diese Leute muss man finden, diese Leute müssen strafrechtlich belangt werden
Das heißt, was wir wollen, ist eigentlich nur sind wirksame Maßnahmen, die tatsächlich was bringen und nicht dieser technisch wacklige Quatsch.
Gut. Dem ist eigentlich nichts hinzuzufügen. Aber vielleicht noch das das Einzige, was ich mich jetzt frage, ist ähm.
Ähm baut ihr auf so Einzelaktionen, also die Leute sollen jetzt irgendwie ihre Parlamentarier anrufen. Ähm.
Frau dran erinnern, dass sie doch bitte den Koalitionsvertrag einhaltet oder gibt es gibt es so Arbeit an so was wie irgendwie Uploadfilter gegen Demos.
Dinge tun, gibt's Stichtage, Deadlines, Formbriefe. Also, erst mal grundsätzlich kann man sagen.
Es wäre natürlich cool, wenn ihr das jetzt schon machen würdet, also Abgeordnete ähm kontaktieren und Nancy Faser kontaktieren, aber was halt besonders,
Wichtig ist, ist, dass die mediale Aufmerksamkeit bestehen bleibt und das bekommen wir auf jeden Fall hin, wenn wir dezentral, regelmäßig Proteste dagegen
organisieren und ähm
Es wird auch noch einen offenen Brief von der Ethri geben zu diesem ganzen Thema. Ähm ähm netzaktivistische Organisationen, die auf der EU-Ebene arbeitet. Genau, also es ist eins die
European Digital Right Accessoation, da sind diverse NGOs, unter anderem auch der CCC Mitglied, ähm die ganz, ganz tolle.
Arbeit im Bereich digitale Menschenrechte machen und es gibt auch eine Unterschriftensammlung von Campact ähm mit einem Appell an Nancy Faser, da kann man auch immer noch unterschreiben
Genau, also da kann man ganz, ganz viel machen
was wir halt wirklich versuchen müssen, wir haben ein eigentlich ein Supermediennarrativ in Deutschland grade und das müssen wir wirklich versuchen aufrechtzuerhalten und auch sozusagen Nancy Facer darin bestärken und sagen so
Das ist deine Chance vertrauenswürdige Kommunikation und Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung zu retten. Bitte.
Mach das für uns. Du kannst eine von den Guten sein, wir glauben an dich. Go.
Äh genau ja das ist das das das braucht es und da kann ich euch vielleicht nochmal ermutigen. Also,
ganzen Deadlines wissen wir zwar alle noch nicht wir sind auf jedes bisschen Fotoaktion und das kann auch ganz klein sein. Also wir haben tatsächlich da zwei E-Mail-Adressen. Eine davon ist Deo at
Chatkontrolle Punkt DE ähm das schicken wir auch alles nochmal in die ähm Shownotes rein.
Schreibt, also wenn ihr Bock habt, auch wenn ihr einfach nur ein paar Friends habt, schreibt uns da gerne. Ich glaube, was es wäre extrem cool, da jetzt einfach, wenn einfach es anfängt, dass Dinge passieren
und wenn ihr Lust habt ein paar Friends aus eurer Stadt, egal wo ihr wohnt
zu sammeln und da so ein bisschen Betreuung aus Berlin braucht, euch wünscht, äh schreibt mir gerne. Ähm ich äh denke mir da gerne mit euch was aus oder baut euch selber auch gerne Transpies und Schilder und so und fangt mit kleinen, coolen Fotoaktionen an
und ähm genau oder Rave-Demos oder was auch immer. Ähm,
Alles ist drin, alles finden wir super. Debus wird Betreuung aus Berlin. Das klingt das klingt gar nicht so. Liefern wir alles,
Alles klar. Sehr schön. Ähm das war jetzt ein wilder Ritt.
Über tausend Dinge nicht gesprochen, aber es war das reicht erstmal, oder? Ich glaube auch genug so, wie es ist. Genau, ich glaube, wir müssen alle tief Luft holen.
Wir müssen uns allen im Klaren sein, dass das ähm ein Marathon wird und kein Sprint und dass wir wirklich alle zusammen dagegen aufstehen müssen und auch nicht aufhören dürfen dagegen aufzustehen.
Das ist jetzt der Anfang mit coolen dezentralen Fotoaktionen. Ich glaube, das macht super viel Spaß und es werden bestimmt auch noch Dinge auf uns zukommen, die weniger Spaß machen als witzige Fotoaktionen dagegen zu tun.
Und ich glaube, wenn man da sich eine gute Crew zusammensucht, mit der man das zusammen macht, dann
kann das wirklich eine gute Sache sein und dann kann man das auch sehr lange durchhalten und diesen langen Atem sollten wir uns auch beibehalten, denn
unsere Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation muss geschützt werden und,
gerade glaube ich noch gar nicht so gesagt. Wir müssen eine anlasslose Massenüberwachung von allen Menschen in Europa verhindern. Nichts geringeres als das.
Bottem Line, das Ding ist gefährlich, das Ding muss weg, macht Demos, kommt zu Demos, jetzt. Alles klar, in diesem Sinne ähm.
Bei euch bedanken, dass ihr sozusagen das so schön und einläuft, nochmal erklärt habt, euch geduldig allen Fragen gestellt habt und ähm ich möchte jetzt noch eine überraschende Wendung nehmen, bevor ich mich verabschiede und das ist ähm.
Viktor. Da kommt ja jetzt gleich ein Song. Ja. Mhm.
Du kannst uns habe ich gehört genaueres dazu erzählen. Was ist eigentlich die Geschichte der diesem Song? Wo wo kommt das her? Was ist hier los? Also ich ich meine diffus mir bekannte Datenschutz Elektro Punkband
die irgendwann mal dazu aufgebrochen ist äh Musik zu machen und äh wie es sich so begab äh ja ist ähm das tatsächlich
Ja, also ich ich wir machen das eigentlich nicht, dass wir also eigentlich reden wir nur zu zweit über unsere Band jetzt mal ganz kurz. Entschuldigung. Ähm ich bin da äh durchaus involviert, weil ich die eine Hälfte vom Systemabsturz bin. Mhm. Was genau das Musikprojekt ist, von dem dieser Song ist.
Und äh dementsprechend kenne ich den Song sehr gut, weil ich ihn bestimmt tausendmal gehört habe, während ich den Beat gebaut habe und ihn gemischt habe und mir das Ganze gedüdelt im Hintergrund ausgedacht habe.
Und äh ja, deshalb ist es natürlich irgendwie ich weiß nicht, ob das auch jetzt der Autosong ist, aber das das kann ich dazu erzählen oder hast du Fragen?
Ja, aber die will ich jetzt wiederum nicht stellen, weil du ja gesagt hast, sie redet nur so. Das sind dieses dieses einladen. Buchen. Wir sind buchbar, sowohl für Festivals
als auch für Podcasts, für Chaos, Radiofolgen. Alles klar, liebe liebes Chaos, Radio Redaktionsteam, bei dem ich mich an dieser Stelle auch noch recht herzlich für die Sendungsvorbereitung
danken möchte. Ähm ich glaube diesmal waren's vor allem war's vor allen Dingen Mo.
Gemacht hat und sagen, ohne den wir heute gar nicht hier technisch zustande gekommen wären. Vielen Dank euch, vielen Dank auch an den Rest und mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen.
Heute wichtiger denn je, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.
Music.